there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
and here we are ladies and gentlemen yes
we're an hour later yeah very dark in it
uh is it yeah i think it is let's try to
get a little hold on
is that better yeah let me bounce this
off of here and sorry about the wire
everybody try that i think that's that
looks a little bad is that as bright as
it goes that's as bright as it goes
that's as warm as it goes because
there's a warm setting in a cool setting
all right uh yeah dj maynack says uh i'm
in north america have to be up for work
at 3 30 a.m is all yeah yeah that's you
know it's we're kind of like i don't
know we're kind of like experimenting
with different times because we just
noticed over the past few weeks that
starting at five we didn't get as many
people yeah and that sometimes when we
start a little bit later
yeah but like i said you know everyone's
in a different time zone so it's really
hard to kind of you know i i get if
you're in like the eastern time zone and
you work like quote unquote regular
hours
like you might be just commuting home at
five o'clock and you can't listen to it
and blah blah so i don't know we're just
kind of like farting around with it and
trying to decide i was always of the
mind that we every now and then ought to
just do it at a crazy time so people on
the other side of the planet can can can
um
be in in the live stream we have thought
about doing that i do kind of feel like
i don't know i feel like probably maybe
what we should do i don't know maybe we
should decide on something because i
feel like maybe what we should do is
maybe like for the regular show um you
know and maybe the side tracks will have
like a regular time but for like movie
movie reviews and other stuff maybe we
could just come on whenever we feel like
whatever right um you know what i mean
because i don't want to make it too
crazy because then people will be like
oh i never know when you guys are on
right but we could have a couple that
are regular times like that are always
at the same time but then the rest of
them we can just kind of like wing it
and maybe sometimes even if we feel like
it like if we watch two movies we could
do two in a day or something like that i
don't know
all right i don't want to like over
extend ourselves because i feel like
we're already on like five days a week
yeah and we have recorded stuff that
goes on the other days because we always
we have something going up like every
day
you know which is a lot so today's show
is updates on uh cases that we've done
in the past
uh new information has come out on some
of them jenny has them compiled i
haven't seen what she's got today
but it's going to be a good show yeah
basically we're basically doing uh it's
like three or four missing persons cases
that we talked about on prior shows that
have either had updates or been solved
recently like in like since we've done
them
and then there are like two unsolved
murder cases one of which i don't think
we ever did a show about it although i
think we might have discussed it
or it might have been mentioned either
in one of my books or we talked about it
i kind of feel like maybe we talked
about it during one of like the zodiac
shows or something about edward w
edwards or something like that lover's
lane murders uh so that and then i'm
going to talk about an unsolved murder
case that i did write about in faceless
villain 2 that was solved like just a
few months ago like through dna
so i mean i'm keeping them brief what i
would decided to do we're gonna do like
you know how the old unsolved mysteries
with robert stack used to do and it's
like they kind of reshow the old [ __ ]
and then i'm not gonna do that but like
re-show the old [ __ ] and then at the end
they're like update you know what i mean
so i kind of wanted to do that so i'm
just gonna like run through
the details
of the original case so you don't have
to let go back and listen to the old
episodes because a lot of them are from
a couple years ago and then we'll just
at the end we'll say like what the
update is okay so that's how we're gonna
that's how we're gonna work
yeah people are down piling in
hugo says tom you're two arrows ahead of
me i don't mind
tb trigger says it's damn too early man
that's too early
i mean i don't know fox obsidian said
i'm good either way i'm a second shifter
so i listen to why i'm at work okay okay
so
i mean one of the original ideas behind
the show is that it was just regular
listeners as friends and [ __ ] to listen
to it while you're working or driving
get up
that was the idea well i mean that's
what i do like when i'm if i if i have
uh you know graphic design worked or
something to do like on my laptop i'll
usually put on my other computer i'll
just put on like youtube videos like
scary stories or true crime [ __ ] or
something like that that i can like
listen to in the background yeah and i
gotta have something on i gotta be
listening to stuff to fall asleep i'd
fall asleep to a pro show like this
yeah i can't i can't fall asleep with
noise going on not not usually unless
i'm exhausted i gotta have noise going
around i can't i can't i don't i don't
like having that i like to put science
on
like uh science yeah i love event
horizon is real good and and what's his
name uh michael gautier like him uh i'll
listen to like avi loeb uh he's talking
about aliens um
all uh
some of this stuff i'll listen to it
before i go to sleep but i have no
intention to fall asleep at the time
like i'll listen to geopolitics but you
know like i'm gonna stay awake for that
but science i'll just fall asleep and
just fall asleep during that one and
then i'll get pissed that i fell asleep
and go back and start it where i
started but you started listening yeah
you started well last night weren't you
listening to
did you start listening to that um
family opera yeah because we were
talking about i added that to the poll
yeah um we're gonna talk about that
we'll see how that goes because one idea
that we had that he just brought up last
night and i said oh that'd probably make
a really good show so i put it in the
patreon poll for next uh week
was uh the real story behind the phantom
of the opera novel the uh gasolarou
novel yeah because apparently it's sort
of kind of based on our true story maybe
and i kinda wanted to like look into
that so there was actually you said you
looked on youtube because you said you
wanted to reread the novel and on
youtube there's an audiobook done by
christopher lee yeah and i was like oh
if that if that uh gets picked i'm
totally listening the thing is now
listen to it is that the christopher lee
audio book does not include the prologue
oh okay well you can listen to that
somewhere else oh this is the prologue
somewhere else and i don't know how much
of it because if the book ridden
completely from the front to the back
is nine hours
okay the christopher lee one is only
three hours okay there's a bunch missing
so it's uh all right i read the book
and read the prologue and everything
and in the prologue
gaston [ __ ]
squares up and down to the story's true
and he tells about his investigation
before he wrote the book to find out the
truth about the legend
and uh he's
he
described and and what he says is a
reality
that
it has been confirmed that opera theater
did burn down on the date in question
underneath it there was an underground
lake that had an island on it
uh evidently bodies were found there
according to gaston that he found them
along with some investigators that went
down there
um
so the
he sweared on it he swore on his
deathbed that it was a true story
he tells where he got the information he
went through the archives
this case was already like 40 years old
when he got into it or 30 or i think 20
years is what he said it was 20 years
old when he investigated it
a lot of the witnesses were dead but he
did find some of them and one guy had
letters
from eric the guy was phantom he had the
letters that he was writing to her
and letters that she was writing to him
and the old stage manager still had him
and he thought that me gaston claims
that he thought that it might have been
[ __ ] but then he found
the the the woman in question some of
her letters and he confirmed that the
handwriting was the same that he
couldn't have forged them
um
read in the book he is describing to the
t
a serial killer
all right
this is long before profiling
he describes this serial killer having a
a disease
that he didn't know the name of it but
when he described it i remember seeing a
disease like that from what i remember
of the description okay it's been a long
i'm getting i'm rereading it again in
audiobook or i'm listening to it again
in audiobook
to see if my memory was accurate but at
the time i remembered the description
fitting
a little kid that i knew in in dominguez
elementary school who had
something wrong with him that looked
like that his head was kind of peanut
shaped and his hair was
falling out
and his fingernails were real thick it
was like crumbly foam
and his gums had pulled back and his
eyes were kind of pulled back he did
look like a skull and he had something
something genetically wrong with him
and
that's how this guy
they call he's called eric in the book
that's how he was described
and he was a genius he's a musical
genius and an architect
a a torturer he had been tortured
for a living for some sultan over in the
middle east he got amazingly rich he
moved back to down france
where he came from
he couldn't fit in society and he used a
bunch of lawyers to buy that opera house
and he built i guess by himself some
kind of a
mansion on that lake where he was living
underneath it and and he was an
architect so he could do all this stuff
kind of like hh homes
yeah see i thought that would be a good
idea for our show yeah so i'll see if it
gets voted i had always heard that it
was fiction
but i believed what he said it sounded
very plausible and this is written in
like maybe 1909 around that time
and he's talking about
the late 1800s
and he's talking about serial killers he
profiles this serial killer in the book
i was like man this is just like this
how could he have guessed this this
sounds just like the real thing
and i was doing some more research a
couple days ago
and it says
right there on his wikipedia of guests
on the road that he's on his deathbed he
swore
that that was a true story and that he
had done the investigation that that guy
really existed
so we're gonna look into it i mean yeah
like i said i went in today and i could
because if you're on our patreon
uh which you should be if you're not
shame on you but i'm just kidding i know
some people can't afford it but whatever
but if you're on there you can vote on
the topic for the following week's show
and you can also vote on the
movie retrospective like the movie that
we talk about on the movie retrospective
you can always vote on those and uh so i
went in there it's usually five choices
that i just picked at random out of my
you know topic jar
and uh so that was one of the ones and i
think that i had already had the poll in
there but i went in there and replaced
something else for it so if you guys
want that then go vote for it and we'll
do it next week
uh dj maniac says there's a new bauhaus
single out today see i can't believe i
didn't hear about that
i mean i've been doing other [ __ ] today
i haven't really been keeping up keeping
up with the news or anything
so
uh yeah is it any good have you heard it
i wasn't a huge fan of their i know they
did that album go away white
when was that i kind of feel like that
was
[ __ ] that was a long time ago now
2011. was it
2012 something like that i can't
remember maybe earlier but yeah they got
back together into that album which was
like okay
it was like half good and half kind of
you know what i mean
um
but you know a couple of songs out there
were good actually maybe it was older
than that
because didn't oh you know what
maybe it was even older than that
because didn't like that heavy metal
2000
didn't that have one of the songs that
was on it like on that album so maybe it
was like 10 years older than i'm
thinking it was i don't know this is
what happens when you get old like
everything was like it was just a few
years ago and they're like no that was
actually 20 years ago
it's like that um he also media sent us
a 10 super chat thank you very much oh
thank you very much yeah guys hoping to
get the super chat bidding started
tonight love the show it's like hanging
out with friends talking about crazy
[ __ ] yeah thank you very much
that was the idea that's what we always
wanted to do well we i mean we can't
really do anything else because it's
like it's not like we're gonna come on
and be be like personalities or like
play different roles or anything like
that we're just like being
our stupid selves yeah we're not
nothing scripted even though scripting
is good too like uh jenny today
just uh sent me something this came from
uh rob levinson
sent her a a clip of [ __ ] razor fists
uh who's a great channel razer fist
dude's [ __ ] hilarious okay now he's
intelligent too real intelligent
razor fist reviewing malone which we
reviewed reynolds
and it is it's [ __ ] hilarity go check
that [ __ ] out i'm gonna go ahead and
plug that [ __ ] well yeah rob sent me the
link and he's like you guys have to
watch this it was like it was only like
15 minutes and i was like okay so i put
it on like in the background and i was
like within a minute i was like [ __ ]
dying it's [ __ ] hilarious because we
just watched that movie like last week
he hit a lot of the same points we hit
but he uh he his his his was scripted
and got a really good edit yeah so it's
it's [ __ ] hilarious it's hilarious
we beat him to the punch because we can
just [ __ ] boom
uh we can cut a video in a day because
none of our [ __ ] scripted so but that
must have been a week of [ __ ] work to
edit that [ __ ] out yeah but it's
[ __ ] there's something to be said for
either because i i kind of like a
combination because sometimes i'll watch
stuff that is
like edited and scripted and written
um you know and that's good too like if
that person knows what they're doing
because that's really funny i sometimes
i like nostalgia critics uh stuff even
though like i said i don't usually like
stuff that's real shouty yeah um
but if it's really funny and well
written and stuff like that then i'll
give it a pass but
on the other hand i kind of like a lot
of channels too that are just like this
one that are just kind of like people
that are just kind of like hanging out
in their room yeah like talking about a
movie and it's not like they have notes
like to refer to but they're not it's
not like written or anything so i tend
to
gravitate more toward that because it
seems more like a real person to me
rather than like a personality i've cut
a past couple weeks i've gained an
appreciation for burt reynolds's work
you know and him as a dude
he was good um burt reynolds as a dude
as just as a dude yeah
when i was a teenager burt reynolds
especially towards the late teens and
the 80s burt reynolds was kind of like
it was it was it was dated
you know that was like something your
dad would watch
but it's kind of come back around in
style the [ __ ] that he's doing yeah it's
corny yeah but it's also kind of cool
it's funny it's okay it's okay yeah
it's uh
it's entertaining the quality was pretty
high even when even the schlocky stuff
is pretty good yeah a lot better you
know
a lot better than a lot of the [ __ ]
that's out sometimes i mean i kind of
like though that a lot of people now
like even younger people nowadays are
kind of like they get like the 80s [ __ ]
they're like even if it's cheesy they're
like all the better they're like that's
okay it was supposed to be cheesy that's
what i mean and it's like and then they
they just like that anyway like i just
think that's kind of cool look man bad
burt reynolds bad burt reynolds is still
a [ __ ] ton better than say like [ __ ]
bad steven seagal it's a lot better than
bad steven segal i feel like the bad
stevens would go well now it depends
because sometimes the steven seagal ones
are so hilarious that they're
entertaining but most of the time most
times the steven seagal ones are just
boring
with like a couple moments of like oh
look at that hilarious [ __ ] where he's
just like using a stepman to like walk
across the room but then like the rest
of it you're just like boring yeah yeah
it's like that like he's just sitting
around like mumbling at people bad burt
reynolds was still pretty good
uh yeah uh good bird metals was great
really like i said if you're gonna make
a movie and you can't be good yeah at
least be entertaining yeah like just go
whole hog with the with the stupid and
the ridiculous and the outrageous it
will be a lot more fun and a lot more
memorable for everyone involved don't
try to be serious don't try to make it
good if you don't think that you can
make it good just make it like the
silliest stupidest thing ever and it'll
be it'll be magic
bad
bad burt reynolds was still better than
bad charles bronson
and bad charles bronson was still
entertaining bad charles bronson wasn't
terrible but bad charles charles bronson
was still better than bad steven seagal
well like i said the worst thing a movie
can be as boring yeah
and and and
and burt reynolds and bronson were never
boring yeah you know they were always
you could always watch the movie and go
okay and get something out if it's not
boring then you've entertained me right
i mean at least make me feel something
bad cigar is boring yeah that's what i'm
saying that's why a lot of his movies
are bad because he thinks he's like
super awesome of being all serious and
everything but mostly they're just dull
and samey
um
you know like i said if you're gonna
make a bad movie just make some crazy
[ __ ] now there is some good bad segal
that i've seen under siege too is bad
but it's good i watched it i enjoyed the
movie uh the director of that movie was
very proud of it he was a guest on one
of our friend's show i don't remember
which wasn't that uh
who was it that had wouldn't that didn't
sariah have him on on oh yeah he might
well did he i think yeah i can't i think
it was somebody i had him on
yeah and uh he actually said did you
like did you like under siege too and i
was like yeah i did i did like on a
siege too it wasn't as as good as under
siege one in terms of like
production quality and and just uh
you know the the casting you know what i
mean because they had some [ __ ] they
had tommy lee jones in that [ __ ]
and and oh crazy man just chewing up the
[ __ ] scenery in that movie there was
a lot of good but she had chew it just
chewing the [ __ ] out of the [ __ ]
under siege one and then they had they
had a little [ __ ] pet house that
little playboy
buddy chick with the boobs who's
popping up out of the cake she was cute
too
in the whole movie so it was a good
entertaining movie it was uh it was a
knock off of [ __ ] die hard
and seagal was
putting out some of his best material
he was
kind of credible
at that point still
you know with the limit with the limit
the limitations of the technology at the
time we you know we didn't have internet
so we really couldn't check up on the
guy
and find out if he was bullshitting or
not a lot of people still believed his
[ __ ]
but undersea under siege one was good
under siege two
was fun it was fun to watch it was funny
the casting wasn't quite as good [ __ ]
um but it was still good enough
uh the bad guy was kind of this nerdy
computer genius and they really couldn't
bring that across
into something that was like a real good
villain but he wasn't real credible
villain but it was still a
fun movie he was going to use some kind
of killer satellite to zap something
it's so vague i don't even remember what
what the [ __ ]
satellite it's basically under siege but
on a train
it tried to be like die hard
which i thought i would have done
i feel like there are so many movies
that are die hard on a black die hard on
a thing
and well dialed i heard it in the desert
die hard on a
camel's back
i don't know i'm just making snowballs
well die hard was doing that
diehard was on a different thing every
time so you know that's true it was
doing that
die hard on a soviet space station yeah
die hard
yeah
yeah so
[Laughter]
it was just they were just movies at the
time you youngsters wouldn't understand
[Music]
they would though i mean i i feel like
they do yeah they were never intended to
be taken seriously
i mean i hope not no uh dj maniac i was
asking about the bauhaus song yeah uh he
said it's an exquisite corpse of a track
they reworked parts from one of their
old songs and sent the files back and
forth oh okay well that's kind of
intriguing so it's like kind of
experimental yeah i kind of liked that
exquisite corpse thing that they did
where they each one of them like all
four of them like did their own [ __ ] and
then they like
stuck it all together i thought that was
like a pretty cool
[ __ ] tom will put on a wave for the
right amount i'll put on a wig for no
money if i'm in the right [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] if i'm in the right mood
called you a [ __ ] just like burt
reynolds called dolly parton and last
little last year the best little
whorehouse yeah we got a review that
reviews up already yeah okay yeah that
was a good movie if you want to listen
to a musical yeah i mean if you're into
a musical and you don't like have to
love country music because i certainly
don't but it's still like a fun uh movie
yeah and
[ __ ] you see dolly parton at her
greatest and she was just this
legendary southern woman of
epic proportions i mean that one
she's floating along at a cloud of boobs
i'm going like jenny we've got to get
you that bra
i said and i'm trying to get i don't
even know if that was just bra that
might have been bra and tape it was a
mixture and like lots of other like all
kind of rigging i kind of feel like
there's a lot of rigging going on under
there well i i i have already
pre-investigated
i pre-investigated
years ago
as i was studying for my master's degree
in blue biology
dolly was never natural okay she would
but although she was
evidently big before she
did you know got implants a lot of
people a lot of people don't realize you
know that
some of these women who were [ __ ]
well endowed like jenny was she was big
before implants
having implants is kind of like putting
on an
internal bra so it makes big boobs look
better
and that's kind of what
you know some girls don't have any boobs
they'll put them in but other girls will
be they'll have big boobs they'll put
them in and make big boobs look better
it's like you got a bra on even if you
don't have bra that's what and dolly was
one of those but she was uh she kept
getting
bigger ones and bigger ones and getting
things done she'll admit it it's no
secret she said you know she'll just oh
no i've had nips and tucks and she's
just
and she's now a monument to plastic
surgery
okay yeah i don't really get why you
would like deny especially in this day
and age no i mean i don't think anybody
does anymore but i kind of feel like
back in the old days but absolutely not
i'm just naturally beautiful i'm like
[ __ ] come on no you're not i have a
lot of respect for dolly over the years
you know what barbara walters tried to
do to her on television that shit's on
youtube you can look that up and try to
humiliate her and everything that was
player hate really because you know
[ __ ] he put barbara next to [ __ ]
dolly dolly blows barbara away you know
what i mean she's [ __ ] jumping on her
for being
some ignorant barefoot [ __ ] trailer
park whatever
man [ __ ] she's trying to throw shade
on her from being trashy yeah but she
but the thing is is that dolly was not
trashy dolly was very classy even if she
was just own the trashy she wasn't
trashy no i'm just saying even if you
were yeah that was her her
that was her excuse she would just you
know what but if you look look at
dolly's history dolly was always very
classy
but she was always
wigs
implants
sexy outfits
so she would make a joke out of it yeah
i'm trashy
she wasn't trashy though she was [ __ ]
very nice woman
uh she just liked to look hot
well women do i mean that was just that
was her
yeah i mean that was kind of her that's
her brand yeah you know what i mean and
she could sing she you know so go back
and listen to her it's all about
branding like i said i think people
understand that nowadays better back in
the 70s they didn't understand branding
yeah okay so like now every instagram
model has that [ __ ] down pat but like
back then i kind of feel like it was
some weird
alien concept or something yeah
but um
she she got and
she she got enhancements as she aged and
she nips and tucks and perfections and
chiseled away but she wasn't the only
one
they were all doing that in hollywood
well i feel like everybody
came out right behind it
like i said and back then it was a big
deal to come out and say yeah i had
plastic surgery because back then
everybody was kind of like operating
under this right illusion
that
all of these women like were naturally
that beautiful when they were like 56
years old which is no not impossible but
uh very very unlikely it's just like
it's just like these [ __ ] fakes like
arnie which i love aren't even that
[ __ ] are fake okay
arnie
and in a way sly even though sly is not
as fake and and these other guys in raw
and the rock okay
they pretend like they don't do [ __ ]
anabolic steroids of course they do
anabolic steroids are you a child which
is dumb just say just like
and the reason why they don't say
is because they would they don't want
people to diminish the work that they've
done oh well you can just sit around
take steroids and get big like that no
you can't
no yeah it's a mixture of everything
they're just supplementing with well
then come out and say that
to me it just seems dumb to like have
this whole like [ __ ] illusion that
you built around here i mean that's
right right i mean people are gonna
fight especially nowadays people are
gonna find out about you [ __ ] so you
might as well just like lay it all out
on the [ __ ] table and again deal with
it
children all those dudes take steroids
they all do yeah well like i said i
think everybody knows that now but i
think there was like some big thing back
in the old yeah no
no we don't do that yeah and we just
work out to get this awesome and all
those people in the marvel [ __ ]
universe we're just naturally this
beautiful oh captain america and all
those girls and [ __ ] they're all on
[ __ ]
okay
tyler says in one of seagal's more
recent movies he sits in a chair for
nearly the entire thing
yeah and it was something in front of
him so you can't see him you can only
see from the [ __ ] chin up you can
see the neck
and when he gives him you only see his
eyes he's gonna wear a burqa yeah and
then he cut away and then he cut back to
him and he's walking away but you only
see him from the back and that says his
body double
he needed a body double to go down the
stairs who is much better well yeah we
left i can't even remember the name of
the
the movie that we watched mercenary for
her justice was it they're all they're
all named mercenary for justice
killer fraud that's that's what all of
them are saying steal justice steal
mercenary for hire like i said they have
one of those like magnetic poetry sets
that just has like
badass it's called badass words i don't
know i just i'm just saying and they
just like you mix them around in their
fridge and be like okay that's the next
stephen seagal movie somebody write a
script for that actually don't even
write a script just write a paragraph
and we'll figure it out yeah
steven seagal just sit in a chair and
mumble at people and squint
and then other people run around and
shoot everybody and it'll all get
resolved in the end so
that's that's a wrap
you know what the [ __ ] was that noise
somebody climbing up the outside house
is that is like like thing pop out oh
[ __ ] i hope not take that
did you [ __ ] out my window
i had this
oh okay
that
see i'm on the second floor like that my
office is right over the garage every
time it rains or the wind blows it's
really loud in here it sounds like a
[ __ ] tornado yeah and
one of these windows had this weird like
this black
um
what the [ __ ] was that like that weather
stripping
and it was kind of like hanging off yeah
so this morning like tom had a trip it's
like yeah like a black trim and it's
like hanging off i guess it came off in
a storm or something and we couldn't get
this window open because like the locks
are stuck or something no it's the
things on the side oh the things are on
the side okay
so this window wouldn't open like for me
to like pull it off so tom had to go in
the gym next door open that window and
climb out on the [ __ ]
roof like a little bit of the roof over
the garage and like pull it off and i'm
just like i was like i'm telling you
right now i think this is a bad idea
please do not fall and splat all over
the [ __ ] driveway just to get that
stupid piece of like weather stripping
off of that window but you know what i
mean that's how it goes yeah
um let's see what was there still
talking about dolly
uh
dolly is the holy mother of lgbtq plus
that's true well how is that she just
has a lot of yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah i'm sure big time well
it's just kind of like yeah like dolly
um you know there it's like it lies in
all that kind of stuff well you know
like i said she was a southern woman of
[ __ ] legendary proportions she
but she's not as insane as some of the
[ __ ] girls that we know that do cam
[ __ ] like [ __ ] princess [ __ ] pinky
and [ __ ] like that you know she's not
like that
really what you know really her [ __ ]
claim to fame was that she could [ __ ]
sing and she could act
her acting was wrong i think the boobs
were just like supplements yeah right i
mean because she did was actually
talented yeah it wasn't just she was she
just had big boobs and she couldn't sing
that well you'd never know who she was
boobs are not you know but she could
sing well her falsetto was as good as a
yodel she i'm pretty sure she probably
could yodel
uh
she's just beautiful beautiful voice
camera she could act camp guy said my
parents had this uh friend a lady that
did herself up with all kinds of scarves
makeup wigs costume jewelry etc it was a
trip my old man once whispered to me
it's all fake
and you're like uh yeah yeah
yeah i just i don't know i don't know i
don't really understand
the whole like thing to
uh you know if you're gonna wear wigs
and makeup and stuff like that i'm
always kind of like well just i'm not
like really worried about whether it
looks real or not well another thing you
hit i don't really think that's the
point of it our parents generation and
part of our generation we grew up in a
time of transition before the internet
before [ __ ] like instagram they were
very rube like they didn't understand
[ __ ] show business they didn't
analyze it they'd see somebody on camera
and they would think that well they
wouldn't realize that yeah that dude's
got a wig on it oh this guy's got a
[ __ ] corset on they didn't really
make up and everything well everybody on
tv has makeup on yeah the men too right
everybody yeah they weren't really
analyzing what you can't put some [ __ ]
with no makeup on on tv it doesn't look
right it looks like a damn corpse you do
um everybody does yeah so they didn't
really analyze what they were seeing but
now in a world of [ __ ] instagram and
social media i mean you have people
[ __ ] doing photo shoots with their
cameras and figuring it at home
realizing that oh yeah you can't really
be natural and make a good photograph it
doesn't photograph right now
if you [ __ ] photograph yourself it's
like our friend sophie our friend sophie
will take a picture of herself on
purpose to look [ __ ] natural and [ __ ]
with no makeup on how i really look you
know she'll [ __ ] point that up to try
to get sympathy sophie i know you're
talking about sophie
look how plain i am and i said
the thing is obviously you don't look
like that
you don't look like that everybody looks
bad in a photo like that that's what i
mean i don't actually look like yeah
when you see her in real life because
her real life without like up and stuff
like that but
um yeah
everybody looks funny funny in a
photograph you don't like the way you
actually look right unless you [ __ ]
have really tweaked that photograph and
prepared the lighting and there's makeup
and touch-ups and camera angles involved
if you just snap a photograph yourself
itself especially if looking in hd
in [ __ ] just average lighting you
look like a corpse it just but that's
not how you look to another person right
who would be standing right there next
to that camera looking at you the human
eye doesn't perceive things that way
yeah i mean if i took a picture of me
like when i first woke up yeah you'd
look bad i would look at it yeah like i
would look like all [ __ ] blotchy and
[ __ ] i'd have big bags under my eyes
and [ __ ] like that you know but when
you're walking around living your life
in the club and [ __ ] especially in
[ __ ] flattering club lighting at
night
nobody looks like that
nobody looks like that everybody looks
pretty good at night
yeah
because it's kind of dark yeah
tb trigger says hey i'll be in florida
at the end of april any suggestion of
things to see or do where are you going
yeah where are you going because
florida's really big so i don't really i
hesitate to like uh
suggest anything because we're not
walmart up there in a panhandle because
it might be like 300 miles away from
where you're going
you know what i mean yeah i'm just
saying like personally i don't know if
if you like theme parks obviously
orlando is good because we have all of
the theme parks um if you like like
history and [ __ ] like that then i would
go to maybe like saint augustine or
which is on the east coast or west coast
maybe tampa st pete kind of area because
they have a lot of like uh cool [ __ ]
going on too seth says everybody looks
good at night after a few drinks that's
right sassy well that's why you're not
building that i'm just [ __ ] with this
yeah
that's why beer goggles are a thing yeah
all right so
man my drinks why i still have a drink
but it's yeah well yeah but it's getting
kind of freshen that up for you gotta
get kind of watery
and i feel like maybe we should start
getting into the show like i said it's i
know that when i said that it was five
or six cases you were gonna like roll
your eyes at me and go jesus christ
jenny but
i tried to keep them brief
famous last words
famous last words you guys know how that
goes and like i said i don't feel like i
need to go
like the the missing persons cases i
don't you know i'm gonna go into the
details of them but i don't really
feel the need to go super super into
detail because
we
covered the cases before like on some
older cases and we're just kind of like
refreshing people's memory about them
because there have been like updates in
the case so there's that
um but yeah i will wait until uh
clearwater i want to see the salvador
dali museum oh yeah i haven't been i
went there
gosh
i went to the salvador dali museum
many years ago and i remember being
kick-ass it was like really really it
was really awesome but it was like
really long time ago that i went so i
don't know if it's been like updated i'm
sure there's like different
stuff there but um i thought it was like
i thought it was excellent
so
yeah i mean so i'm trying to think i
lived in the clearwater
tampa area back in the early 2000s
i was a big fan yeah the dolly museum is
great uh
what they used to call the south florida
museum i don't think it's called that
anymore but if you look up that it'll
tell you what it's called now uh that
was really cool they had a lot of really
cool like artifacts and stuff and i was
really into the aquarium there too they
had like a really
they had a really awesome uh aquarium in
the tampa area which i used to go to all
the time when i lived over there but
yeah the dolly museum is like is super
cool
i mean there's a lot i didn't live in
tampa long enough to
really give too much of a [ __ ] uh
thing like i don't know i live like i
said i live more
in the on the east coast like daytona
saint augustine kind of area um and in
the
central florida area like orlando sort
of thing
honestly i'm trying to go through most
of florida going from panama city to
daytona but we'll go out of my way to
see something interesting daytona is
actually my hometown that's where i was
born so if you drive past halifax
hospital
that's where
little bitty baby jenny was born at back
in way back in 1972 very long time ago
and i actually grew up in
holly hill
right off of derbyshire avenue
if you know where that was the
derbyshire avenue i guess for sure
i think it's avenue i can't remember but
yeah it was a long time ago um i moved
away from there probably 2010
2011 something like that
but my brother still lives there though
so pookie's asking for some food over
there
what like wet food or treats wet food
this is ridiculous there's wet food in
the in the little mini fridge okay she
wants me to clean this off go ahead and
start the show and i'll clean this
i gave her some this morning and she's
still you're a little piggy poke
she's a little piggy yeah
i mean i usually only try to give her
like
a
a healthy like tablespoon of it there's
some in the refrigerator
yeah that's gonna have to soak a little
bit
i know
it's
i have to like clean it like really
every morning i get in there like scrub
it with the [ __ ] sponge and [ __ ] like
that because she's spoiled she's got
little feeding dishes and trays all over
the [ __ ] house
feed stations jackson galaxies you
shouldn't do that like because you your
cats will get fat yeah but because if
they can just eat whatever they want
then they will they will yeah but
she is getting a little fat if you ask
me
stop body shaming her
it's a pouch
she is a little junky yeah but
she that's okay
she's still very energetic it's not like
she just lays around like look how fat i
am you know what i mean it's like she
runs everywhere yeah so she gets a lot
of exercise we just need to cut her down
a little bit
i'm spoiling her too much
she's like right too much but she knows
what you're talking about she's like oh
i don't like this at all yeah i don't
like what you guys are talking about
yeah okay let's get some let's get to
the all right so uh she's not fat she's
thick
[Laughter]
she is kind of and like i said she's in
good shape she like runs around and
stuff like that she runs around all
night i can hear yeah all right so the
first case and i think i brought this up
like briefly most i got the idea to do
this show
because so many of you guys sent me like
updates on some of the cases that we had
talked about and i was like oh we should
do a whole show of those so that's where
i got the idea so so thank you for
sending the updates yeah um yeah it was
like several different people that sent
me hey did you see this hey did you see
this so it's like i kind of like
compiled good job
and uh yeah
crowdsourcing
and so i picked i mean a lot of cases
because of dna
a lot of cases an alarming amount well
not alarming like an actually pretty
awesome amount of cold cases have been
solved
because of like dna [ __ ] like i said how
they famously caught uh you know the
original night stalker golden state
killer um but i wanted to focus on ones
that we had covered previously so i kind
of went back through our old creepy
disappearances shows and [ __ ] like that
and looked for stuff that we had talked
about before because i wanted to update
those and i think i brought this up on
one of our sidetrack shows or maybe i
brought it up on one of our other shows
like a few weeks ago because somebody
sent me an update on this let's talk
about the brandon lawson case
this was like a very very high profile
missing persons case and a lot of people
like a lot of channels covered this like
when it first happened just because
there were 911 calls and it was like the
circumstances around it were so weird
and [ __ ] like that we first talked about
this case back in early december
of 2018
on episode 120 on one of our creepy
disappearances shows
so let's kind of like talk about
uh
what happened with this why everybody
got so fascinated with this
so brandon lawson disappeared
on august 9th 2013.
he's from san angelo texas
so what happened
the day before that august 8th or the
night before
he comes home
uh and at his house he lived with his
girlfriend uh ledesa lofton they had
been together for 10 years
now
according to her
they got into an argument um sometime
between 10 45 11 pm
now the thing they were arguing about
was the fact that brandon had not come
home allegedly the night before
and uh so ledessa was upset that uh that
he maybe he was falling back into
because he had been um
had some issues with drugs in the past
although he had supposedly been clean
for six months at this point so she
believed that he had backslid uh and
that's why he hadn't come home the night
before so they apparently got into an
argument about that
um
now his brother though says yeah that's
probably what happened um i think he
maybe he took some meth i don't know if
that's true or not but that's what his
brother said his brother's name is kyle
by the way
so around 11 30 at night uh brandon
calls his dad who's in crowley or
crowley texas i'm not sure if it's how
you pronounce it i'm not from texas
could be crowley could be crap though no
they might say crowley in texas that's
what i figured i just said crowley
because of aleister crowley yeah yeah
you know it takes me crowley that's what
i thought of
uh so he calls his dad now his dad lived
about three hours away
so he calls his dad crowley
they would say crowley crowley crowley
yeah
it would they wouldn't mississippi it'd
be crowley
okay that's just funny
she threw me out of it so i'm trying i'm
trying to get southern with southern
with the thing and now if in mississippi
that'd be crazy it's just the littlest
thing and sometimes like we've known
each other so long that sometimes when
i'm doing the notes for the show
like sometimes i'll be reading and i'll
be like oh god we're going to go off on
a whole tangent like that on that word
yeah yeah or we're on that like
statement or whatever so i'm like should
i take it out is this show going to be
seven hours long
so it's like
these are the things that i that i have
to like think through yeah because i was
like just i know that it's gonna be like
i kind of thought that maybe that would
happen there well yeah i had i had to
use my [ __ ] pros my ai calculator
to try to redneckify that [ __ ] word
and
got a redneck yeah like if i had a
thousand of them trying to read that
word how would they pronounce it that's
that's how i'm well see i was kind of
thinking that too and you know i'm not
gonna like [ __ ] on you too much because
i get hung up on that [ __ ] too cause
like sometimes i'm reading about
something and there'll be a word and
then i get and then i go off on a whole
like rabbit hole about
we'll wait about the pronunciation of
that and then that leads to some other
situation and then i'm off on a hold up
you don't know what we're talking about
they don't know they're all regular
you know how we do you know we can't
help it no this is just how we are
we can't help it but yeah we we both do
kind of that same thing but it's just
funny that a lot of times when i'm
reading through the notes i absolutely
know
when you're gonna like go off on a
tangent not always because sometimes you
like come in with something that i'm not
expecting but not usually usually i can
be like oh right there that's where it's
gonna go off the rails
so sometimes i take it out i'm not gonna
lie don't take it out leave it in there
they're paying for this [ __ ]
they're paying for this yeah but i don't
want to stay here for seven hours i'm
gonna fall
all right
i'm already sleeping i'm gonna let jenny
jenny i'm just i'm gonna let jenny jenny
well thank you i appreciate that
for now for now
and now i need a shirt that says that
i'm gonna let jenny jenny yeah
yeah
for now for now
[ __ ] might have to step in
and on jenny
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] all right so where were we okay
well yeah we got distracted by the name
of the town and i'm not gonna say it
again okay
anyway so the dad lived three hours away
so brandon calls and says hey i'm coming
to see like three hours i guess because
he had a flight fight with his
girlfriend so okay
so a little before midnight 11 54 p.m
uh brandon leaves his house apparently
to drive to his dad's house
uh driving his car which was a silver
ford f-150
now at about 12 30 in the morning on
august 9th
uh brandon calls his brother kyle and
says hey i ran out of gas
and i got pulled over on route 277 uh
between san angelo and bronte texas
kyle later said that during this phone
call
brandon said three
expletives quote unquote so [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] i don't know
what the word was exactly
are chasing me out of town yeah it could
be three goddamn [ __ ] are
chasing me out of town i don't know it
just says expletives which is funny in
this day and age yes it's like just put
the word come on it's okay pokey
three pookies are chasing her down
pogba's looking to be rolling over okay
go ahead okay she's trying to get me to
play with her i can't play pokey i'm
working i mean you can you could like
throw some stuff out i gotta go clean
clean the plate in a minute yeah that's
right yeah you have to let it soak for a
long time because for some reason that
wet food
she loves it but as soon as like an hour
after you put it on the plate it's like
it's like concrete yeah and then you
have to like soak it for really and then
you have to scrub it off with like
[ __ ] uh like [ __ ] steel wool
um so yeah so yeah three expletives are
chasing me out of town three
[ __ ] let's say [ __ ]
uh and later said no it's the mexicans
in the neighborhood the mexicans are
chasing him out of town
okay that's they want their land back i
guess i don't know but that's what he
said well see
these weird phone calls are why this
became such a high profile case because
it was like what the [ __ ] was he even
talking about um like i said his brother
said he might have been on that i'm not
like judging the dude because you know
something bad happened to him but
um
you know his brother did say that maybe
he was on beth i'm just saying because
he did say some crazy [ __ ] like on the
phone
um
so at this point his brother uh asked
him are you hallucinating
uh and brandon said no
uh and then kyle
and his wife and their four-year-old kid
they drove over to
the to brandon and the girlfriend's
house and got uh like a gas can
and so while the whole time that they're
driving between the house and between
where the truck was supposed to be he
kept like calling his brother
but kyle said well brandon wouldn't um
like maintain a conversation with him
it's like he'd usually like say a couple
sentences and then he would hang up so
it was kind of like this really weird
situation
now 12 50 a.m brandon called 911.
and told the person on the other end of
the phone the the responder
he said i ran out of gas and then i need
the police
during this phone call which you can
hear online it's everywhere
he says some weird [ __ ] he starts saying
stuff like yes i'm in the middle of a
field and then there's like an inaudible
bit
pulled some guys over
right here going toward abilene on both
sides that's what he says my truck ran
out of gas there's one car here
the guy's chasing something something to
the woods please hurry that's what he
says
it's very very garbled chasing my ass
into the woods maybe maybe
um so yeah like i said if you want to
hear the 911 call like i said just look
it up just brandon lawson 9-1-1 call
it's all over youtube you can hear it
everywhere
um then a couple minutes later uh
another call comes into 9-1-1 from a
trucker
that's that was going by and he was
reporting
brandon's truck because it was
apparently like parked all crazy like in
the street and it was like dangerous
so between 12 50 a.m and 1 15 a.m
brandon apparently both received and
made a whole bunch of calls
with his brother kyle his girlfriend his
neighbor
and the 911 dispatcher
but his cell phone reception was really
shitty
so a lot of the calls that were coming
into him would go straight to voicemail
after 1 19 a.m all of the calls uh went
to voicemail
now around
118 though like a minute before that
happened kyle his brother called brandon
and said later that he did get him to
answer and he said brandon sounded like
he was gasping like out of breath
and said that brandon said that he was
bleeding that's what it sounded like
um
so at this point uh a sheriff's jet
deputy shows up at brandon's truck
but he gets there and brandon isn't
there he's not at the truck
kyle gets there a couple minutes later
this was 1 10 am and like i said this
was like a little bit before like the
weird phone call where he said he was
bleeding
but when he's on the phone
he gets to the truck they find the truck
him in the cop
and
brandon on the phone
says
i can see you i'm right here
but they're looking all around and they
can't see him like they don't know where
he's at like i know it's the middle of
the night but you know
so
what they're speculating okay so brandon
at this point
did have an arrest warrant out on him
presumably for drug charges i'm not
entirely sure
um so maybe when the cop showed up he
hid although that's dumb because he
called the cops
and he said he needed the police please
hurry so it'd be dumb to like hide from
the cops i don't really know
but
he says i can see you i'm right here but
they couldn't see where he was
so
kyle the brother talks to the cop
and then he drives up the road a little
bit and parked and he's like waiting for
his brother to like show up because he's
apparently like right there he said i
can see you
um and he waited for like 45 minutes and
he's like [ __ ] this and then he took off
now because he's like at this point he
just thought well his brother ran out of
gas and he's just like tweaking out on
something i guess i guess that's what he
talks
so kyle leaves the gas can uh in the
back of brandon's truck
and kind of goes a little bit away and
then he came back like a couple hours
later about five in the morning
uh thinking that brandon would be gone
or that everything would be resolved but
when he got back there
um the truck was
like still there and brandon was not
back yet
about three hours after that at eight in
the morning the truck actually got towed
now after this obviously everybody kind
of like wigged out or like where the
[ __ ] did this dude go like they couldn't
find him anywhere
so uh you know the deputy the sheriff
everything like that they have a search
party they looked everywhere like around
the [ __ ] truck
um and they had flown planes over the
area and they didn't see anything
suspicious
now obviously his family and a lot of
like internet sleuths and stuff like
that um kind of kept this case alive
over many many years because like i said
this was 2013 that he went missing we
covered it in 2018 and as i said it was
all over like all the true crime [ __ ] i
think every single true crime channel on
youtube like covered it at least once
because it was so weird like the
the 911 calls and stuff like that were
so weird and they couldn't figure out
like where he gone
so this was very very high profile
but it turned out
that what happened there was an update
to this like very very recently like in
february of this year
what ended up happening was that there
was a there was a private property not
too far away from where the truck was
now apparently the owners of this
property i don't know if the cops had
searched it at the time because it was
private property um but the owners of
this property apparently didn't you know
watch youtube or didn't really know
anything about the brandon lawson case
and they were just completely oblivious
as far as i know
so uh i don't know if their property was
ever searched but after a while i don't
know if the cops initiated this or if
there was like a guy who's kind of like
an internet sleuth slash
missing persons investigator he kept
like pushing and he was kind of finally
like got in touch with the owners it was
like we really need to search your
property so they did that
so they uh so they searched this
property and they found on january 15
2022
uh some clothing consistent with what
brandon was last seen
wearing
and then at that point uh the cops were
called and then they found they you know
looked they stretched out they searched
the area
and then they found
human remains
uh these were found about a mile from
where brandon's truck ran out of gas
now they're still doing the dna tests
they haven't confirmed the identity but
the fact that they found these human
remains right where brandon's clothes
were and a mile from where his truck was
found uh his family are pretty well
they're like we know that's him were the
the remains were buried
um i don't know actually i don't know if
they
because i think what might have happened
it seemed like from his weirdly
from his weird phone calls i kind of
think what happened i don't know if it
was like some kind of road rage incident
or something like that i think maybe
he
like pissed off somebody like on the
road and they maybe shot him
and then maybe he just i don't know if
he died where he fell i don't know if he
got murdered i'd have to i'd have to
hear the recordings
to see if he was acting or bullshitting
or if he really was really worried
could he have
faked this attack
and actually committed suicide
i don't know it really didn't seem like
i mean from all the stuff that i read
it didn't really seem like he was
i don't know i guess they always say
look he wasn't the type of person to do
that but you know
that's hard to say there was
the case of a guy who was flying his
cessna
his dad i think was an air force general
if i remember correctly
he's calling in a damn ufo sighting
and then
plain lost
never did find him
but i don't believe he was abducted by a
ufo i believe he committed suicide he
just
he just didn't want his family to know
that he had committed suicide
so he faked a yeah
a ufo abduction
and maybe
some people like the idea if they're
going to kill themselves anyway to go
out to go out like and be like a big
mystery yeah
like i could i could see like right i
could see wanting to do that this kind
of sounds like that
it's implausible
if dudes are after you
i don't know it just doesn't usually go
down like that i mean was somebody after
him from before
dude it just seemed like they're gonna
kill you usually they kill you on the
spot and there's all kinds of videos of
it it's usually not a long drawn out
process they overtake you they kill you
this just seems very strange like he
just decided apparently i don't like i
don't i'm only going by because he's
dead obviously
so well you know when they confirm the
dna i'm assuming that he's dead yeah
it's him um yeah well his family are
like yeah we're pretty sure that's it
they haven't confirmed it yet but
they're pretty sure
um but it's just weird that
so apparently according to everybody
he had a fight with his girlfriend and
this was like spur of the moment he just
decided at the spur of the moment
supposedly
i'm gonna drive three hours to my dad's
house i don't know if he was gonna stay
there because he was mad at his
girlfriend i'd he maybe there was nobody
closer he could stay with or whatever
but he's just not i'm gonna drive three
hours at like midnight
to my dad's house and then somehow like
on the highway on the way there
somebody
apparently
like
made him pull over he said he ran out of
gas i'm just not buying this and then i
mean it's very i mean it's not
impossible i've heard weirder [ __ ] yeah
but you run out of gas
and then you just call like how
likely would it be that some car full of
legos mexicans or mexicans or murderers
yeah pulls over i'm not saying it's
impossible it does happen
but it's just i don't know it's just not
that likely so i don't really know
i think that's why everybody was so like
interested in this case because it's
like the details of it are so weird like
what could possibly
what could possibly have happened y'all
can tell me what you think in the
comments section
but uh it does it doesn't smell right to
me
i suspect suicide
kelly g makes a good point
meth which his brother said that he
might have been on
because he had had drug problems in the
past
he had supposedly been clean for six
months but his brother said that maybe
he would have backslid
um and and maybe that's what him and his
girlfriend were fighting about because
she said
because she said that he'd been out the
whole night before and i'm gonna
make you hallucinate well no she said um
she says it makes people paranoid yeah
and they think they see things that
aren't there especially if they've been
up for a couple days so it could have
been yeah he might have been up for a
couple days so it could have been
that he had backslid so i don't yep and
he thought somebody was after him i mean
he did die it's yeah i've been drinking
but you're now you're now
folding in some so i'm not sure if
somebody did actually kill him because
the thing about it is that they did find
his remains but they haven't released
the manner of death yet
so i'm not sure if there was like
gunshot wounds or something like that
because it was skeletal remains obvious
it might have been an exposure
or yeah it could have been itself in the
head you don't know
but now that you're laying all this into
me none of me and [ __ ] it's coming
back i'm not gonna back off what i said
suicide
he may have not intentionally killed
himself but he killed himself
he was smoking meth went [ __ ] crazy
allegedly i probably i mean maybe it
would explain a lot yeah
but to be honest i'm not judging i'm
just saying it a real violent attack
takes place in a single location it's
not usually a big drawn out
or deal with your run and this that's
it's just not how it got i mean [ __ ]
grandparents isn't here he's a federal
agent [ __ ] law enforcement agent
he'll tell you when an attack happens
it's a point
it's a it's a point target it happens
right then and there it's not some big
drawn out
thing well and if it was somebody that
knew him that was like after him for a
beef how would they have known that he
was going to be on that particular
stretch of road at that time because
apparently it was like a spur of the
moment decision to go to his dad's house
statistically attacks take place in a
single location at a single time it's
not a big drawn out chase type thing
so i'm just saying statistically i think
that his i'm being chased by a bunch of
mexican stories is unlikely
it's unlikely it's more likely he's high
on meth
and he's maybe just like thinking yeah
honestly you know what might have
happened is that somebody maybe pulled
over to help him and he's and he's
wigged out right and he wigged out
thinking these people are out to get me
or something like that and ran away into
the woods and he's calling they're
trying to get me and and oh and his
brains fried because of [ __ ] not
sleeping and all that math and then he
dies of exposure i mean that kills
himself somewhere now that i'm saying it
out loud that absolutely kind of sounds
okay
to me
what what's up poop what's the matter so
uh to the to the surviving family maybe
not so much suicide more like accidental
accidental uh overdose
although like i said i don't know what
the cause of death is yet um
exposure yeah or something that kind of
self caused
he wasn't in his right mind
that's more likely not saying that's
what happened i'm saying statistically
just more likely that's what happened
yeah because like i said it is it it
does happen but it is very rare
to just get killed by what are you doing
she tries to get into every damn closet
you've been asking and going you know
what happened last time you got in that
closet you don't remember mommy
remembers she stands up and you almost
strangled herself
if there's a closet or a door she has to
go in that's ridiculous you you stop
that's the closet where she almost
strangled herself on my bra so i said
okay no more closets for you what a way
to go strangling on a bra
damn
oh my god it's just you guys had to go
that's the way to go
okay i thought you want to be smothered
by boobs
not just a bra
smothered
but no i was just saying like you guys
remember because i talked about it
like i found her
it was morning at least so i was awake
and i heard her like choking so i went
and i found her in the closet and she
was like strangling the bra and after
that i was like nope no more closet for
you
and she is so mad about it every morning
she scratches on that closet door and
she's like
me and i'm like no back to this case to
me this doesn't sound like a plausible
situation or a story he's high
that would explain a lot like i said
he's uh he's high and
he did something that resulted in his
demise
yeah i mean i'd be kind of like now that
i'm thinking about it i would actually
be kind of surprised if he was murdered
yeah
um it might have just been yeah it might
have just been like a really unfortunate
like i said it might have been that
somebody pulled over and like tried to
help him and like he wigged out and like
ran into the woods and they're just like
okay what the hell is this dude he goes
out in the woods and somehow dies of
exposure or i don't know maybe meth
could make you overheat i don't really
know uh everything that meth can do to
you
i mean [ __ ] man we've had [ __ ]
trying to eat other [ __ ] faces
in broad daylight with that guy well he
didn't try he actually kind of did he
did it
oh there's no telling this sounds drugs
are bad okay drugs are best well not all
not all of them it depends
i don't want i don't want to say that
across the board cheap street drugs are
bad drugs are fun yeah if you don't
spend any money for them don't take that
[ __ ] okay
there's a reason why they're cheap okay
[ __ ] yeah i don't want anybody taking
that [ __ ] and eating my face yeah go go
[ __ ] go on youtube and go look at
what flakka does it only costs a couple
bucks but you why would you spend a
couple bucks you get what you pay for
you give it japan
buy or beware that's what i'm saying
camp guy said i once knew a guy that
would get so drunk he would pass out and
then piss his pants and or bed because
he didn't wake up i kind of feel like
that's pretty common and you see that um
[ __ ] you can see that now it's like if
you go on youtube or something like that
like sometimes they're like hey look at
these girls that were out of mardi gras
or whatever and they got so [ __ ] up
that they like fell asleep in a gutter
and then pooped themselves yeah so and
obviously someone's gonna film that [ __ ]
yeah don't have anybody our cute little
[ __ ] friend showing you a [ __ ] i
threw her ass over my [ __ ] shoulder
to carry her drug ass out of the car and
she pissed down my [ __ ] back emote
remember that [ __ ] happened she peed
down my back
i mean i've never done that but i will
admit to being like drunk and then like
going in a bar bathroom like to throw up
and then while and while i'm throwing up
like sometimes i pee a little bit i
don't know like why you're throwing it
up a little bit man so then you gotta
like clean up yeah yeah but you know
that's never happened to me i like
throwing up though
it's weird like that like i get it but
i've never liked throwing up i'm better
about it now than i used to be i used to
be like very i'm there i know there's a
word for like um for a phobia about
throwing up i totally used to have that
no i love throwing up i still
he does and he's talking to jenny
throwing up like it's nothing to happen
well he's like real controlled about it
too because we'll be like driving
and he'll be like
hang on a second and then he'll just
like that
yeah all right so
and i'm just kind of like how could you
even [ __ ] do that like we had that
like one time we were like even hit
targets and [ __ ] yeah we were drunk we
were like kind of like walking in the
house and you were just kind of like
hang on and then you barfed in the
bushes yeah and then you're like all
right and then you just like went in the
house and you were fine yeah we're just
hilarious yeah it's hilarious i don't
fight it
just go with it i try to fight i don't i
hate to throw up you're fighting it i
know don't fight it it's happening
because it has to happen
yeah but it's like there's too much
alcohol in your stomach well it's like i
don't want to like barf in my lap or
some [ __ ] like that i don't have to
clean that [ __ ] up you just have to be
real cool was it hold on get ready get
rid of this it's just like back in
ancient rome
they had [ __ ] trying to vomit
tickle in the back of your throat with a
fence
like that okay and then you go back to
eat some more so you could eat more you
eat more and
you got to be classy about it
hopefully they had a breath mint that's
all i'm saying yeah i think probably
wash your mouth out [ __ ] drink some
water you know go back like this because
that's some [ __ ] i think about them like
did they at least like don't get wrapped
up in it you're not getting wrapped up
after
it's just you know i mean it's it's like
another body's function it's like taking
a leak or something
it's just coming out to this end
that's better you know what i mean and
then i
throw up i'll be talking to jenny i'll
be having a conversation and throw it up
a little bit like that
[Laughter]
i mean it doesn't happen that much i
haven't thrown up from drinking in a
while it's been a while
so
i'm getting better about it
because it's trying to keep you from
alcohol getting out the last time
actually it wasn't that long ago but i
will say and i think i've said this on
the show before because every now and
then i'll get like i was like oh i'm in
a gin mood tonight and then i'm always
like well i'm only going to drink a
couple because if i drink too many gins
i will throw up because it's very very
maniac says it's the last time i threw
up yeah it was because i drank gin
maniac says turns out vomitoriums are
myth what is the thing is the vomitorium
was not where you threw up yeah
was that it was an entryway
or an exit way out of a large room
that's not what they're talking about
but people in in in rome when they went
to the [ __ ]
la train where they were they where you
go to the bathroom did throw up
they threw up
uh that way they cuz they were drinking
yeah they were also doing drugs
um we just don't know what drugs they
were doing or maybe they figured out now
but back
back last i heard this is [ __ ] 20
years ago the face eating drug
there's all kinds of receipts from
things were left over in clay pottery
that ended up down in the [ __ ]
landfill roman landfills
with uh receipts of how much you bought
and it supplies obviously for a party
it's got [ __ ] all the [ __ ] food
and all the drinking
and um
words for things keep popping up and
it's some kind of drug
and there's four or five of them that
romans did but they don't know what it
is they're talking about they don't know
if it's weed or cocaine or
something but they must have had some
kind of
i would think that it was opium
because they were trading with the china
with china and the far east i would
think that they knew about opium
i don't know if they smoked it they
probably drank it
because there's no records of any kind
of smoking or injecting anything
they tended to from what we know drink
things
you could drink opium you'd get it
wouldn't be efficient but you could get
zonked on that
uh you could probably you could eat weed
so well yeah they probably did that
there's lots of different uh ingestion
yeah options there's all there were some
um different kinds of lotus type things
that the egyptians the ancient egyptians
were really interested in that they were
probably eating that they said was
probably hallucinogenic
so they so uh the ancients did get high
and they were unabashed about it the
mexicans were definitely getting high
they were taking all kinds of
hallucinogens they were big into
scopolamine
it was one of the ones that they would
take
um did we do a show about this about all
the i kind of well no we did a show
about
uh angels trumpets and like that which
is scopolamine right yeah i think it's
what is if you make tea out of it right
yeah the uh the maya
the maya and the aztecs were a maya
subtribe
um
the mexican and central americans and
even the south americans uh
[ __ ] were a
[ __ ] very proud highly developed
civilization the the spanish
recorded a lot before they destroyed it
okay
which is [ __ ] crazy even the [ __ ]
friars spanish friars that were there
were like listening to the vatican going
wait a minute hold on you want us to
burn all this
it was [ __ ] insane
their their literature was
according to the according to the
spanish friars
equal or even surpassing
ancient greek writings
so this is they were very highly
developed uh civilization in terms of
literature he had a fantastic calendar
with a good mathematical system and uh
decent understanding of
of architecture
it just didn't know anything about
fertilizer that was the problem
it would deplete the soil around those
cities and collapse after a few
generations a mexican city or central
american city didn't last long that was
a problem they didn't understand about
fertilizer fertilization is [ __ ] very
important or you can't renew the land
so you end up having to sacrifice people
thinking that you're repaying the blood
debt oh
it's not growing so we're doing
something wrong kill these people
that'll
which is population reduction that'll
solve everything that'll solve it you
know
uh
but now you know [ __ ]
here in the americas we had badass
[ __ ]
strange
civilizations like the ancient egyptians
they were called the mexicans
people forget the [ __ ] they're not
looking at it the right way
the olmecs yeah the old max well that
was even pre before all that
and some of these people we're not even
sure where they came from you look at
the statues i mean a lot of them look
like something from
the pacific islands so you know the
easter island which is right off the
coast of chile
kind of looked like something
out of hawaii to a certain extent the
way that people were described they were
just
so man there's just a lot of mysteries
about the plat the past everybody was
seafaring everybody had their time in
the sun
and now that the modern world's here we
can all appreciate each other but we
were all
traveling all over this place yeah i
mean everybody kind of figured out a
boat yeah people were going everywhere
um
but yeah you know it was a be a badass
time to be 13 years old back in those
days it was a [ __ ] a time of
adventure like conan days
time wants to go back to that
i want to go back to that yeah yeah
maniac says when you throw up you're
still drunk and you get to start over
yeah yeah i've had that happen a few
times now
i will say okay uh for you guys maybe
bars are different like different bars
are different
yeah i've been at the bar a few times
and i'm just kind of like i get kind of
drunk and i'm just like okay um
i have to go to the bathroom a second
and then i'll go puke and then
like then i come back and i'm like i
feel much better and like i'm fine and i
can drink more although i usually stick
to water after that now you can't let
them catch you doing that though because
if they catch you
throwing up they'll throw you out
because they're like yeah you're too
drunk to be in here but if you're
discreet about it
you can't barf all over everybody or
barf out you just go in the bathroom and
barf discreetly and then come back out
be cool about it then you should be all
right then you can start over like i
said
uh so yeah camp guy says uh maybe he
walked out into the desert died of
exposure all they got is bones yeah like
i said i kind of feel like i try to see
if
because the last update i could find
about the brandon lawson case was
february 4th 2022 and that's when they
had sent the dna for analysis
and
as far as i know uh as of this live
stream they still haven't identified it
although they're pretty sure that it's
him they're just trying to confirm it
but they haven't released uh the cause
of death
so i'm interested to see
if it was murder
or if it was
accidental like i'm gonna put my money
on accident
i mean we'll see i don't know if i want
to like i don't have enough money to
like put money on anything but
statistically he's not the target for
violent crime
i kind of feel like not and like i said
it's yeah he said somebody was chasing
him and it's like
not yeah that's not impossible but it
seems unlikely it's unlikely it seems
more likely he got high and um
and thoughts
which is sad in itself and died
i don't want to see by his own hand
i don't
we don't know maybe probably not suicide
per se but but died by accident
which is kind of which to me is like
kind of sadder because it's kind of like
he may be i don't know if he was on
drugs or not he might have been but it's
just kind of like you do that and you're
not really thinking oh that you're gonna
die
well no that's a bit we'll know later
but that's what that's feeling like to
me that's what i mean that seems like a
really [ __ ] tragic
that really could have been like avoided
um so that is very sad and like i said
i mean i kind of feel like his family
even though they haven't had the dna
results yet are pretty like they've kind
of come to the
they've come to terms with the fact that
that's probably him
um you know they found some closure it's
been a long time for them you know he
disappeared in 2013
and i imagine
that they had probably long ago come to
terms with the fact that he probably uh
was not alive anymore
so you know i like i said i've never had
anybody i can't imagine what it must be
like
to have a family member
that is just gone and you don't know
what happened to them so i can sometimes
see how
obviously finding them dead after all
this time would be
horrible and would be upsetting but at
least you would know at least you would
know what happened to them
so at least you could like just close
that chapter and like move on i kind of
feel like when they're still missing
you're like in this weird like limbo
state you know what i mean so i get that
that would be like worse
in some ways that might be worse than
like knowing that the person was dead
because at least
you know knowing they're dead that's
awful but it's like at least you know
that they're gone and like you know that
they're never coming back i kind of feel
like if they're missing and they maybe
conceivably could still be alive
then it's gonna like [ __ ] with your head
so you're gonna
the whole time you're gonna be like well
maybe maybe they could still come back
maybe you know what i mean and that's
ugh that would be like an awful
i feel like you could never like
progress or you could never like get on
with anything you know what i mean
because you would never you wouldn't now
so all right so the next case that we
want to talk about so like i said uh as
far as i know as of february 2022 they
haven't completed the dna they're pretty
sure that it's him because they found
all the clothes and stuff uh but they
haven't released
uh so so he is dead
um but they haven't released like the um
you know the way that he died or
anything like that so we don't know what
actually happened
but i'm sure that will come as they do
more investigation into the remains
so the next case that i want to talk
about uh was alyssa turney now we talked
about her
back on episode 187 which came out march
17th 2020 on one of our again creepy
disappearances cases i feel like we've
done um
[Music]
like six or seven six volumes
we've done a lot of creepy
disappearances shows because i do like
four or five cases on each of those
shows and i think we've done six of
those
so we talked about a list attorney on uh
our march 17 2020 show episode 187
now
what ended up happening okay so this
happened in 2001. alyssa turney was 17
years old she was junior in high school
and she lived with her stepdad
michael turney and her stepsister sarah
alyssa's mother uh was dead
and michael had three older sons but
they were again older so they had
already moved away
now uh because alyssa was the
step-daughter and sarah was the
biological daughter there was some uh
you know
their relationship with
michael turning was very different
obviously uh his with his biological
daughter he was a lot
more laid back
loving maybe
but because alyssa was the stepdaughter
for whatever reason he was very strict
he watched where she was going like
pretty much all the time uh very uptight
about her
movements like wouldn't let her go here
and there kind of like modded her all
the time
so
their uh relationship was very very uh
strained to say the least
his excuse for it was oh well she needs
more direction in her life so
you know my daughter sarah she's got a
good head on her shoulders she can like
do whatever
but alyssa she needs more guidance so
i'm gonna like watch her like a hawk
uh which
if you've ever been the parent of
teenagers or if you've ever been a
teenager you know that doesn't work out
the way you think it's gonna work out
may 17 2001.
this was the last day of school before
uh they let out for summer break
now on that day uh alyssa's sister sarah
who was again michael turner's
biological daughter
she was actually they had done her
school had done like an end of year kind
of thing like at a water park like in
town
and michael was supposed to pick her up
uh when they came back from the water
park at three o'clock at the school
but he didn't show up
so sarah ends up walking to her friend's
house being you know she's like what the
[ __ ] so she goes to like to wait for him
and uh so later on like a couple hours
later
uh her dad finally shows up
and says to her when she picks up when
he picks up sarah hey your sister alyssa
is missing like she never came home
so at this point sarah um calls alyssa
and she couldn't get in touch with her
like calls her phone
they get back to the house
and michael says why don't you go check
her bedroom
in alyssa's bedroom they found uh the
all the stuff that had been in alyssa's
backpack
was scattered all on her bed
and her cell phone was left on her
dresser
next to her cell phone there was a note
and this note said
dad and sarah
when you dropped me off at school today
i decided i really am going to
california
sarah you said you really wanted me gone
now you have it
dad i took 300 from you that's why i
saved my money that's all this note said
so now sarah didn't think this was all
that weird because
alyssa because she didn't get along with
her stepdad michael
had actually been talking about moving
out to california to live with her aunt
uh so
she's like oh well maybe she actually
did decide to do that
so at this point though michael the
stepdad uh supposedly gets worried uh he
was an ex-cop himself
so he calls the cops and reports alyssa
as a runaway not as a missing person as
a runaway
so the cops opened a missing persons
file
but they didn't really do any
follow-up on it
because
michael turney the stepdad
said well i know she's a runaway i know
she's in california she was planning to
go to california and stay with her aunt
because me and her didn't get along so
i'm assuming that's where she is um but
i'm just like reporting it
a week later
michael the stepdad
said to the police i got a call from her
between four and 5 a.m and this call
supposedly came from riverside
california
on this call according to him
alyssa said i'm unhappy with my life uh
you're the reason i left you suck
and then she hung up
uh the cops looked into this but were
never able to verify this call
and couldn't uh find a copy of the
recording this was 2001 so i'm not
really sure how
you know nowadays they can like track
cell phone calls like all over the
[ __ ] you know all over the [ __ ] but i
don't know how the [ __ ] was in 2001
um now interestingly michael because he
was
a weirdo
had a bunch of monitoring equipment
around so like cameras like recording
like audio recording [ __ ] like all
around his house
for whatever reason because that's a
normal thing that you do apparently
um
so they asked him about that the cops
and they said um
so did you get a recording of the call
then because you have all this recording
[ __ ] around your house he's like oh it
wasn't on because it was the middle of
the night
convenient
so yeah
so several years go by as i said because
this was 2001.
so
uh
after as the years are going on michael
starts telling uh
his family members and other people who
knew alyssa
that he was of the opinion that
something terrible had happened to her
he said this was his story
he said um
i gotta search for her myself because
the cops aren't taking this seriously
and they're not looking for her
um and he supposedly took a bunch of
trips out to california to look for her
and like he made flyers and like handed
them out and stuff his story was that
there were these two guys
that
were in the same i think it was like an
electrical union as him
and that he had
done some like whistleblowing [ __ ] on
them and they were mad so his story was
that they had killed his daughter
in retaliation that's his that's been
his story like i said i think i covered
this on the last one but i'm just
you know catching everybody up on it
in 2006
um which is five years after she
disappeared
the cops get a lead from this guy named
thomas heimer now she was he was in a
prison in florida on a murder charge
and he actually sent the cops a letter
saying that he had killed alyssa
now uh so for a long time they
investigated this lead but they
eventually found out it was a hoax but
while they were investigating that
particular lead
they found out that a lot of stuff that
was going on with like the step dad
story was like totally not adding up
so uh so they look back into the case
seven years at this point alyssa had
been missing
she hadn't contacted any of her friends
she had not contacted the aunt in
california that she was supposedly going
to live with
she had eighteen hundred dollars in her
bank account and it was still there had
not been accessed
her social security number was unused in
seven years uh which means obviously she
hadn't tried to apply for school or get
a job or anything like that at least
with her you know real social security
number
um and then they also found out that the
day she had gone missing the last day
before summer break 2001
that she hadn't actually been to school
all day
what it ended up happening
was that she was at school in the
morning
and then her stepdad
picked her up at lunchtime
and this was corroborated by her
boyfriend
um and her boyfriend said yeah alyssa
told me that she was leaving early but
that she would see me later that night
there was this party that was going on
because like i said it was end of term
so they were gonna have a party and she
said yeah i'll be at the party later my
dad's picking me up early i'm leaving
so that was corroborated by her
boyfriend and several of her friends
so uh what her stepdad said was that
yeah i picked her up we were gonna go
get lunch
and then we got back to the house and we
got in a fight
and then i was just kind of like yeah
whatever [ __ ] her and then he went off
and like ran some errands
they also kind of looked into michael
turney's past a little bit and they kind
of like searched the house and whatnot
they said this dude um
not right he was super super paranoid
like i said he had like uh
cameras all over the house where he
filmed everything was going on in there
and out there he had like audio
recordings on all the phones and
everything he monitored all of the phone
calls uh incoming and outcoming like
everything that was going on inside the
house he was like recording it
uh there was even a hidden camera in the
vent of the living room so he was like
recording [ __ ] that was going on in the
house which like i said not normal
um now the cops once they found this out
were like well can we see the videotapes
from the day that alyssa disappeared
and he said
oh i already looked at them and there
was nothing on them
again
suspicious
um they're like okay well what about the
audio tapes and he's like oh uh that day
though the recorder was turned off it's
a loud different experiments there are a
lot of excuses i mean damn yeah i have
excuses which like i said i mean the
cops are suspicious like they can't just
arrest anybody on anything like
obviously this guy looks suss as [ __ ]
but they can't just like arrest you
unless they have like some actual
evidence
so at this point though because he'd
been so cagey
uh they were like they got probable
cause so they actually did search the
house
while they were searching the house they
found
26 homemade pipe bombs
and a 90 page manifesto always got to
watch the dudes that are like right
manifestos
in the management of manifest you need
to write a manifesto that's a red flag
it's all the red flags they're just
waving he's going to write a benefit too
yeah tom's manifesto yeah i don't know
what i'd say
yeah what are you going to say in your
benefit you know what though
no don't take this the wrong way but
you're totally the type of dude that
would write about yeah
okay i write a manifesto well because
sometimes you go off on like these rants
and stuff and i'm like that kind of
sounds like a man
like you could just like write that down
that would be a manifesto
so in this manifesto uh he said
that
alyssa his stepdaughter had run away
and
he kind of like laid out his theory that
these two guys from this union that he
used to work for
um
because he was a whistleblower they were
like taking revenge on him by killing
his stepdaughter
he also said in the manifesto
that he had killed these two men
but police looked into that lead and
said the two men were dead but they died
of natural causes he didn't kill them
unless he was like really really sneaky
about it which i'm not i'm not i'm not
buying
uh so the cops always they also found
like a whole bunch of paperwork and a
whole bunch of like audio and video
tapes but they didn't really find
anything from the day that alyssa went
missing
they did however find some letters that
alyssa had written
saying that her stepdad had molested her
yeah we knew that was gonna and they
also found some weird like parent-child
contracts which apparently he had forced
her to sign
saying that no my stepdad totally didn't
molest me okay sign here kind of thing
he killed her so there's that
um yeah so and they interviewed all of
her friends and [ __ ] like that again and
they said oh yeah we've all heard and
even a teacher at the school said yeah
she had told us that her stepdad was
molesting her and had told us about a
couple of um incidents where that
happened yeah
so uh okay so they hauled michael turney
in for the pipe bombs
and he actually uh pled guilty to that
so he ended up serving 10 years in
prison for that
um and he went underwent like mental
health uh thing and they found that he
had like paranoid personality disorder
clearly
um and he had to go to like mental
health treatments but
august 21st 2020 he was officially
arrested
for
the disappearance of elissa attorney now
they are going for second-degree murder
charges because they don't have a body
so they're calling this a no body
homicide they are absolutely thinking
that he was responsible for her death
because they're assuming that she's dead
um they don't have a body but they're
still trying to go after him for murder
anyway
but he was in prison for the pipe bombs
thankfully no he killed her but yeah
well everybody thought that but like i
said they don't they didn't really have
any evidence to like prove it
um you know when they searched the house
and they found that other [ __ ] they're
like oh thank god we can like put him in
prison for some other stuff while we're
like but they still haven't found her
body they don't know where she's at but
they're assuming that he killed her she
called him on something and he's like
[ __ ] you gotta go he killed her
that's what happened
i think even
she was gonna go
i think even when we covered this case
the first time like back i think it was
in spring of 2020
um
you know that uh that everybody was
pretty sure that her stepdad had done it
but they couldn't prove it because
yeah because he was like super
[ __ ] not helpful about the [ __ ] he he
got he did something with the body
you'll probably never find it but no he
did it of course yeah yeah i mean like i
said i'm pretty sure everybody thought
that i don't think they ever had any
other suspect
it's just like i said that they can't
really prove it so i like that he
finally got what was she again 17. yeah
yeah he killed her but um yeah he
finally got uh arrested for it
officially like i said they don't have a
body
so
they're trying to go for second
second-degree murder though
it's very hard to prove when you don't
have a body but
i don't know that's not as hard as you
think i mean all the circumstantial [ __ ]
yeah i mean that seems like a jury
i probably i kind of feel like well
because he was in prison for other [ __ ]
too he's he's clearly a crazy person
yeah and there's like a history there so
you know well they were saying that he
that their molestation was going on
that's enough to get that's enough right
there
yeah you know there were witnesses that
said that she said that
yeah and it's just a lot of witnessing
like i said teacher friends boyfriend
everybody said that
she had told me like yeah yeah that's
what that was yeah
all right talk about something i gotta
pee all right i'm sitting here looking
at the cat and that cat is getting fat
she's not fashionable she's cute but she
is getting fat no you get
your belly is starting to stick out on
the sides
i'm just talking to you okay i'm just
talking to your poop because you just
walk around and you eat whenever you
want to eat
see
and i don't shut you off she asks for
the damn chew sticks these little tuna
i think they made by sheba she loves
those things i give her four of those a
night she'll bag give me give me a stick
and i'll give her a stick like that
she'll chew it down to nothing until
it's about like a inch long and just sit
there and just lick the end of it
forever i'm like come on
and if i drop it on the ground she was
ah she's mad runs off because she wants
me to just sit there and hold it or she
can just lick the end of it she's funny
she's [ __ ] hilarious let's see what
you guys are talking about got a lot of
people in there 41 people
totally the guy says yeah i remember
this dude he was crazy
crazy ass piece of work yeah yeah that
dude did that
murder hornets is in
okay
rebecca's in there rebecca done
seth says that dude sounds guilty as
[ __ ] that's right says that that dude
did that [ __ ]
what's up pokey is daddy being with you
no is he body shame again yeah
everybody says i can't follow up vomit
with more alcohol
however i can drink again with the
hangover fixes it straight away
yeah hair the dog yeah the right thing
for a reason
no i can throw up like it didn't ever
happen i feel good i'll just get
something it depends like sometimes i
can like i've been at like i've been at
eye bar
and
what
if sometimes if i don't eat before i go
or like just eat like a little bit
before i go and then i drink a lot i'm
just like oh man i'm gonna like puke but
then i'll go puke and then i'll be fine
but then usually after that i'll still
drink but i'll like
uh you know i'll do like drink water
drink water drink water which actually
i'm kind of starting to do that from
like the start now
that's always the better we head home
we'll go to mcdonald's and we'll i'll
get like a dab
big mac i'll get two or three big macs
if i can i don't care
i don't need the fries
i'll steal some of jenny's fries yeah of
course he will and i'm just like goddamn
it
[Laughter]
because you know i do yeah
we actually the last time we went out we
went to the starry night show
uh last week
we were actually going to it wasn't
super late when we left because they
played at like 10 or 11 so they were
done by like midnight
and then tom was like oh we should i
mean we weren't hammered i just i sucked
a beer i didn't even like drink hard
liquor all night i had like maybe three
or four beers
so i was like tipsy but not
not inebriated at all
so he was kind of like oh we should go
to like mannequins on the way home
because it's on the way home but by the
time we got back to sanford it was like
1 30 and they were gonna close in like
half an hour and he's just like man
there's not any point in it but
it was saturday night so the mcdonald's
was open
because i think you guys that was like
last time we were coming from memento
mori which is monday nights
you know the mcdonald's by our old house
isn't open 24 hours on monday nights
anymore probably because nobody
you came there you know what i mean so
it wasn't like worth keeping it open but
i was like but it's saturday night maybe
it's open and it was so i was like whoo
so i got a quarter pounder and fries i
was like yay i'm like iced coffee
and then you know so i eat that and then
you come home i take three or four
aspirin
and then i get up at like four or five
in the morning to go to the bathroom and
then i take two more aspirin then i wake
up the next morning and i'm fine usually
although i will be very very very sleepy
the next day about 3 or 4 p.m like the
very the next afternoon like i'll feel
fine
in the morning and everything like that
but then like three or four afternoon
like in the afternoon comes around and
then i'm just like oh i'm getting so
sleepy and like i start like my eyes
start to close but there's that
um
yeah tyler says uh i agree with that tom
said she did something he perceived as a
threat to his authority he killed her
yeah i kind of feel like that's probably
what happened and like i said i think
that's what everybody thought happened
it's just that they couldn't really
prove it so at least they finally
arrested him for it i kind of hope he
gets guilt because he sounds like a
[ __ ] nut case
i wanted to comment about this shirt
oh yeah there you go that was the
opening band we saw starry nights we
were talking about that that was the
opening band laboratory yeah it's called
laboratory laboratory
and uh it was these two girls and a dude
and they're up there singing it's almost
kind of like a real dark version of kmf
dm and uh they had this little girl
she's probably about four or eleven
maybe five feet tall
skinny big booty [ __ ] she was down in
a grave and she comes up out of there
and [ __ ] and she's singing with her
damn contacts on being a vampire
princess
it was a good little show i thought it
was fun and i go bit in the back and
they're selling merchandise and this is
the ugliest shirt i ever saw that but i
don't understand that [ __ ] is [ __ ]
crazy looking and i said i'm gonna buy
that
like i said it looks okay from far away
but well it's hand drawn it's hand drawn
i've never seen anything i mean i guess
he it kind of looks like modern art in a
way but i just
to me that's not branding but i still
bought it so i guess i was the sucker
i was well because we like the band i
like the bad we like to support like you
know lego bands just supporting the
local band we got an australian sure
laboratory but it's white laboratory dj
maniac might trip out on it i don't know
because all the all the um starry night
shirts i think all their black ones were
gone yeah so we had to buy a whiteboard
so we had to buy a white one yeah so
they didn't know that we made shirts and
i said dude i make shirts you make
shirts yeah i mean i can make that shirt
i mean they do big runs so i'm not
really sure but i mean because we can
just do one at a time yeah i told him i
said look [ __ ] we could do small runs
i said if you want like limited edition
40 20 30 40. yeah where are your guys we
can do that if you want like 800 yeah
i'm not doing that [ __ ]
have to do one at a time just doing the
shirts for absolution i was just kind of
like i was flipping out that and that
was like what like 80 shirts 100
something like that i think it was 80.
and that was and that was a [ __ ]
nightmare but that was just because they
wanted it was like last minute they
didn't like finalize the design until
like
two days before the actual event right
and so i was like [ __ ] scrambling to
like get the [ __ ] done because like i
said we just made this we make the
screens you can only make one at a time
i don't have like a shop you know what i
mean we just do them in here
um
zach says oh we have zach showed up
salutation [ __ ] i just made my way
back to the hotel in the french quarter
where i'm eating my ass uh oyster oh boy
wait are you eating someone's ass are
you just eating like an oyster
po boy or both let's find out
let's find out
all right so uh gotta get tom a skinny
puppy shirt yeah you should probably
yeah yeah give me one you don't have one
do you
i don't think i have one either now that
i'm thinking about it do i
i have some i don't have one i have so
many [ __ ] t-shirts i don't think i
have a skinny poppy one i think i did i
used to but i think it like fell apart
all right so the next case we're going
to talk about is and this is one that a
lot of people sent me a [ __ ] about
the sherry papini case
we originally talked about this
on i think the same show that we talked
about the brandon lawson one uh episode
187 march 17th 2020
uh how long have you all been online
today let's see uh an hour and 47
minutes we're still at the beginning of
the show really
i mean we've talked about two cases but
i still have a couple i still have a few
more so you didn't i mean you missed
some stuff did zach show up yeah oh
what's up that's what i just said okay
yeah
he doesn't listen i was answering
messages
dj maniac says i have a skinny puppy
tour shirt from the show i worked 17
years ago it goes for about 500 now yeah
i ain't playing that yeah
okay uh is that dj maniac saying that
yeah
you know uh
dj you remember remember that remember
the uh [ __ ] skinny puppy song where
they're out there [ __ ] dancing and
[ __ ]
uh they're they're breakdancing out in
the middle of the day in [ __ ] detroit
it's anything does it hit me in the
streets hit me in the streets
yeah i don't remember the name of that
song but
that was right
that [ __ ] video was shot right
outside a city club in detroit
and [ __ ] it's just funny to see that
[ __ ] during the daytime kind of funny
that was some 90s [ __ ]
but uh that's where i used to hang out
used to see skinny puppy there all the
time
they were older than me though i didn't
hang out with them africa those
[ __ ] were too cool back in the
day you know they were too cool i was
[ __ ] my goth points were low back in
those days
i was kind of nude the scene you know
that was like
that was even before i was in the army
that was [ __ ] late 80s that was like
87 18 i mean i would have looked to
scans at you 89 maybe 88 88.89
cause i've been like
ew who's this newbie
you weren't even born
in 89 yes i was you were like back at
home i was 17 17 all right in 1989. okay
all right
i was a junior in high school
what are you doing i graduated in 1990.
city club the shelter
and st andrews hall
if you [ __ ] look in the first and
last and always album in the inner
sleeve when you opened up you see the
sisters of mercy and behind versus
science says detroit's finest theaters
that was right next to the majestic
theater back in those days but in those
days
i was in brazil they were there a little
bit before
i was uh uh in detroit but
a couple years later i was there
uh detroit was a [ __ ] cool place in
in in the mid to late 80s it was fun
it was like something that's why the
crow
you know the first movie the crow that's
why it was [ __ ] set there
it was [ __ ]
bizarre man it was like beirut it was a
city just being destroyed a gigantic
[ __ ] big city with a very low
population there weren't very many
people in it and it was mostly abandoned
and
you only really kind of had two peop two
different kind of people there you had
[ __ ]
gangsters
black gangsters and white goths and they
didn't even [ __ ] mix there was no
i could walk around it i lived on cass
corridor for a while which is like
one of the most dangerous places in
detroit i could walk around and [ __ ]
never have anybody [ __ ] with me because
they would they would they ignored me i
was white
but they would kill each other i'd
[ __ ] walk out of the back and [ __ ]
remember one time i went out behind my
at the wellesley apartment building
where i lived in [ __ ] second west
hancock
office off cass corridor came out and
saw some [ __ ] black dudes [ __ ]
frozen ass feet coming up out of the
damn dumpster and somebody took his
[ __ ] shoes off just these [ __ ]
socks
they were killing each other and
throwing each other into the dumpsters
it was a drug war
it was some [ __ ] wild [ __ ]
i heard it's calmed down a lot
but
just the way it was back then that's why
that's why robocop was supposed to be
happening in in detroit robocop was
supposed to fix it yeah robocop was
supposed to fix that [ __ ]
it was wild
it was wild uh but you know it was good
times
it was good times for [ __ ] the goths
that were living there
and from my understanding [ __ ] from
from from from the black dudes it was a
good time for them too it was just
yeah they were shooting each other up
but it was it was the drug trade it was
like getting well as long as you didn't
get shot as long as you didn't she get
shot it's all good right
it was kind of like you know it was kind
of like every day is a new day yeah i
didn't get shot yeah well it was kind of
like [ __ ] uh prohibition days between
[ __ ] you know
italian mobsters it was it was like for
them that's the way it was
but they were they were having fun we
were having fun but they were getting
killed though but
hey they were they were
willingly going into the game i mean
that was kind of like their gangsters
they weren't really [ __ ] with people
that weren't not involved no they
weren't that i got to hand them to that
very rarely did an innocent person get
killed it was usually somebody that was
in the game
it was between gangsters
well that's kind of why like i said when
i wrote my faceless villain books i was
like yeah if i want to do like every
unsolved murder there would be like 40
bajillion yeah um but a lot of them are
like you said gang related you don't
know who did it
but you know that that's why it happened
and
you know because they kept that [ __ ]
between them between them i would run
into gangsters all the time and crack
heads trying to sell me [ __ ] and they
were cool to me
because i was no threat to them you know
white boy's not a threat to them
um
yeah you had crazies every now and then
but i didn't run across them and as long
as you weren't in the game as long as
you weren't a white cop or you weren't
a [ __ ] enemy gangster you were all
right
bought my first pistol in detroit from a
crackhead it was a cd75 that was missing
the [ __ ] barrel and the firing pin it
was susp
as [ __ ]
i was like wait a minute what the [ __ ]
because they thought that you could
trace firing pin and [ __ ] rifling you
know well they're just you know just
they're trying to be safe i guess
it was a tan full ego [ __ ] cz-75 an
italian one
eventually put it back together i don't
know
how dirty that [ __ ] was but it ended up
back in mississippi and i [ __ ] sold
it off to a good owner right
but that's just the way it was back then
yeah
just good times good times
hugo says if you like the crow watch
dark city i agree yeah yeah i've heard
about it um you've never seen dark city
no oh you should the crow was a
documentary if graham was in here he
[ __ ] worked there as a law
enforcement agent federal law he'll tell
you that yeah that's a documentary
that's the way it was
so a lot of the crazy [ __ ] i tell you
people
is rooted in my background being brazil
detroit military stuff i'm not
bullshitting there's a lot of [ __ ] i
haven't told you guys about just not for
public
but
yeah
yeah this is not fantasy there was wild
west [ __ ] happening
you know and uh
but like like jenny said like i said a
lot of it was voluntary
you know if you ask for trouble you got
it
if you kept your nose clean you were you
okay for the most part
it was rare that an innocent person got
killed i mean it does happen it does
happen but
it's happening more now when some of the
[ __ ] that i hear about happening in
chicago where just some little kids are
getting killed in crossfires
that's [ __ ] terrible but that's not
what most of it was in detroit
in detroit there
it was
a little more targeted
yeah rebecca was saying i love the movie
the crow but i felt like i needed a
shower after seeing it that movie and
its tone to me epitomizes the 90s yes
it is
that's like the 90s in one movie yeah
and that's the way detroit was back in
those days and devil's night was a
reality that was the night that you
would burn down [ __ ] abandoned houses
and that's why detroit got demolished
it's most of it's gone because it was
abandoned
everybody got chased out of it
you totally should see dark city though
yeah i want to see that yeah
i mean
i kind of i can't believe you haven't
seen it because it's like it's exactly
all the kind of [ __ ] that you would like
yeah okay i want to see it i've seen it
a couple of times it's really good and i
feel like a lot of people i don't know i
feel like it's a little bit like under
the radar
like i do see some cult classic type of
people talking about it but
i feel like it doesn't get talked about
as much as like the crow or something
like that but it's like
it's a similar vibe but it's like a lot
more sci-fi i lived in the wellesley it
was an apartment building [ __ ] second
west hancock off off [ __ ] cass
and then for a couple months i lived in
another place i don't remember what it
was a cattle slaughter house and i
forgot what it was a converted cattle
slaughter house and that one was only
250 bucks a month i could drive my 73
mercury montego into a cattle slaughter
elevator and have it go up to the third
floor where my apartment see i love that
idea and it was i want to drive
it was like some [ __ ] out of batman
that's excellent and i'd have it i'd
have [ __ ] homeless goth girls living
in there with me for a while they'd only
be for a couple days and they'd go in
and out and the layout didn't make any
sense there was no way to heat it that's
really why i left it there was no way to
eat it yeah you're going to freeze your
[ __ ] rosemary you'll die ass off
that's the oldest [ __ ] i mean that's
michigan that's no joke there was no way
people freeze today that's why i was so
cheap man and there was no way to heat
it and um i i [ __ ] ended up in my
[ __ ]
living in one little room even though
there were like seven or eight other
ones
living in one little room with an
electric heater it's like that's like i
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here i get in
the [ __ ] so
i [ __ ] caught i [ __ ] talked to
steve and he goes no i'll get you in at
the wellesley we got a friend that's a
manager there and i [ __ ] went into
the wells and it was it was civilized
there
but [ __ ] you know i live about eight
nine months at the wellesley and then i
joined the army well i went back to
mississippi and then joined the army you
guys just brought in a barrel like
instead of firing like the bums but
before winter hit the place was awesome
i just wasn't yeah i mean michigan i was
a teenager i wasn't thinking ahead if
you're not from the united states yeah
michigan gets
20 degrees below it's a bit cold
it's siberia of america literally if you
don't have heat you will die in your
right in that particular place that's
why it was only like two like i said i
think it was 250 or 275 a month and it
was [ __ ] huge it was like something
out of damn batman
it it it was a goth lair
it was a cattle slaughter house tom
paddle there yeah well i was only there
for about four or five months the
[ __ ] hate
it got too cold it got too damn cold
you're like yep it got too good i
thought it was cool because it was super
cheap so no heat everybody's like until
the winter came and i think i'm getting
the [ __ ] out
steve got me out of there [ __ ] that
steve got me out of there oh my god i'm
gonna dive experience in my own [ __ ]
apartment yeah i get it
[Music]
all right i didn't have a sleeping bag i
was just on a [ __ ] mattress on the
floor [ __ ] wrapped up with blankets
and she was 20 degrees below zero and i
gotta get out of here
you didn't like start a fire in the
middle of your apartment no no
i would
burn some furniture
i wasn't properly prepared
for the winter
in that place
i was young i i didn't have the
foresight
i didn't realize what was coming
yeah that was the day that was like i
said i mean yeah
really any kind of like midwest that
winter there is like no joke yeah tyler
the guy that says tom chillin in the god
bat cave is the level of alpha we all
wish we achieved yeah
yeah but i was like [ __ ] 19
i was like 19 at that time
i didn't didn't know any better i mean
it's it's more fun to like talk about in
hindsight yeah and actually like living
through it no yeah
uh
if you'd moved me back into time with
the wisdom that i have now i would have
been able to play it play my hand a lot
better but everybody says that
when you're young you're dumb
yeah [ __ ] uh when you get older you
know you know how to play your hand a
lot better
and i would have [ __ ] made more money
and outfitted that place to where
winners would have been
survivable you know but see that's kind
of the [ __ ] of human life isn't it is
that when you're old you're like man if
i could go back in time yeah i could
have fixed it i could have done that but
you can't you're right you can't no
that's just
and you and it's funny because you can
tell younger people because i i've tried
to i mean i try not to because i know
how that sounds
but
you try to tell younger people hey you
don't do this than the other but it's
like they're not they're just gonna do
what they're gonna do
and honestly i know they're gonna do
what they're gonna do because i was the
same way you're not gonna listen to
older people
once you get to be old
you know
and it's like just don't bother don't
bother telling younger people don't do
this than the other because they're
gonna do it anyway you know what i mean
they're gonna do it anyway i did it
anyway everybody does it anyway that's
just how it goes
it's it's been like that since
humans evolved from [ __ ]
from from [ __ ] apes so
you can't change it
you can try but you can't change it all
right so let's talk about the sherry
paffini case because
uh yeah we we talked about this as a
missing person's case even though again
this one was very this was very
suspicious uh we talked about this back
in march of 2020 on episode 187
i can't remember exactly like what all
we covered in this so i'm just gonna
like give you a rundown of it because
there's been some
like a definitive solution to this case
let's say which everybody kind of knew
was happening but it's been definitively
approved at this point
so this happened november 2nd 2016.
sherry papini's husband keith
comes home from work
and his house in mountain gate
california nobody home his wife isn't
home and his kids are not home which is
unusual
so he calls the uh daycare where his
kids are and they're like yeah uh
they're still here like nobody came to
pick them up usually the mom comes to
pick them up
uh so he decides he's gonna run the find
my iphone app on his wife's phone
so he does that and he finds the phone
and it's located near sunrise drive this
is where sherry would usually go to
do her daily jog
so he goes there
and about a couple of feet off the road
he finds her phone and the earbuds
very he says they were very neatly as
though they were planted there left in
the dirt on the side of the road
the phone was playing their wedding song
which was everything by michael buble
boobly is that how you pronounce that
i'm not really sure i know that i've
seen that dude's name i don't know how
you pronounce it
uh and i don't know that song
but that was their wedding song so it
was playing on there on a loop
he said even at the time in 2016 it
looked like the phone had been
placed there as like on purpose and he
thought that was weird
so they start looking into sherry's
background she was 34 when she
disappeared
um
so when they start looking into her
background they found like a bunch of
weird [ __ ]
so they look into her phone contacts and
they find like something very strange
there are two men
in her phone contacts
that are listed under women's names
which seems very fishy
one of these men um apparently had come
to visit her in 2011
and uh they kind of had a lot of like
flirty text messages going back and
forth throughout the years so there was
that
uh the second dude
said when they found him they said yeah
i met her at this youth program in 2000
and we dated for a time now this guy
very interestingly
said that sherry was quote unquote
attention hungry
and
quote fabricated stories of being the
victim of abuse from her family father
and then him like the boyfriend after
they broke up
so
he said that during the investigation
and this is while she's still missing
now uh so yeah
at this point like
okay so everyone's kind of like
wondering what has happened could it be
that she was actually kidnapped could it
be that she disappeared to get attention
because when they look into her
background a lot of people said yeah she
was like kind of the the sort of person
that would like make up like some crazy
stories like for attention so it just
seems like another one of those
um and one of her main things was like
she would make up
stories about being abused like as a
child and stuff like to get attention
three weeks after she disappeared
thanksgiving day 2016
she suddenly turns up again
the california highway patrol
they responded to a call on interstate 5
near woodland
a bunch of people had called 9-1-1 about
a woman wandering onto the highway
this was sherry papini
when they found her her hair had been
like hacked off all [ __ ] up like all
chunky
uh there was a chain around her waist
she was very very skinny she was already
skinny but she had lost a lot of weight
and she was uh covered in a bunch of
burns bruises and she had like a weird
brand on her right shoulder
yeah what year was this again 2016. i
remember when this happened
this is a very very high profile yeah i
remember when this happened
so uh so they bring her in and they
start questioning her they've done like
a bunch of like interviews with her but
her this was her story her story was
that on the day she disappeared uh she'd
gone for a run as she usually did
she said that there was this suv like
black or dark blue or whatever and it
was kind of following her
and this suv had two
hispanic women in it
she said one of the women like beckoned
her over and said
that she needed help with something
so sherry goes over there to help them
and then she says that one of the women
pulled a gun on her
and like forced her into the truck at
which point sherry said well i'm gonna
leave my phone here as like evidence you
know what i mean so that's kind of she
she thought she was like thinking ahead
she leaves the phone there
where her where her husband found it
now uh she said that even though
she was very very scared at being
kidnapped that she slept most of the way
to where they were going so she didn't
exactly know where she was taken
um
she said she didn't remember being taken
out of the vehicle
she said the first thing i remember is
waking up in a room
she had zip ties around her wrists
and was in different clothes to what she
had been outing like jogging in
um she didn't say that they'd given her
any drugs although it was noted that she
asked the police
can you lose your memory from being
tased
and the cops said
probably not no but
interesting that she asked that i'm just
saying
now she says while she was in captivity
during this three weeks she says these
two women mostly spoke in spanish she
didn't know what they were saying
she said that she was kept in a locked
room and they were playing loud music
from a speaker that was like you know so
they
you know couldn't hear her and she
couldn't hear them
um
but she also said despite all this
that anytime she made a noise
the women would come running into her
room
and would threaten her one of their
threats being we're gonna sell you to a
cop that was one of the threats she said
like a cop would buy it
a woman i mean
okay baby there have been a couple cops
that were serial killers but i'm just
saying that would be very very rare all
right i'm gonna sell you to a cop
so after they find sherry like i said
three weeks after she disappeared
and like i said when she turned up and i
hate to like [ __ ] cast aspersions
because i know people
get abducted and they get like [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and there's all kind of like
crazy reasons for it so there's no
reason to immediately suspect
but this girl's this woman's story
was pretty suspicious from the outset
and i kind of feel like people thought
that even in 2016. it sounded a little
implausible
so they find her they put her in the
hospital because she's kind of [ __ ] up
now they sent her clothes that she was
wearing when they found her to the lab
for dna testing
september 2019 the dna comes back
uh obviously her dna is on it but they
found a dna profile of an unknown
male
so they put that through for familial
testing which is one of those things
it's like i said it's similar to how
they caught the golden state killer
where it's like not that person's dna
but if another person related to them
has like uploaded dna somewhere or
something like that so they can like
triangulate where the dna came from
so they did that
they found a match
this match uh the dna belonged to an
ex-boyfriend of hers
which they thought was very interesting
so in august of 2020 and this is where
the update starts because this is
several months after we first talked
about this case
august 2020 um they actually went to
this ex-boyfriend whose dna they had
found in her clothes and said what's the
[ __ ] deal
so he said okay i'll tell you guys what
happened
he says that what happened
um
i helped sherry run away
this is from the fbi affidavit this is
what he says in his interview
he says um yeah i knew her since since
we were teenagers
he says she called me up out of the blue
quote unquote
and claimed that her husband was beating
her up and that she was trying to escape
so this ex-boyfriend who is unnamed in
all the sources
he says okay so what he did was he drove
from his house in southern california
and he drove to reading california on
november 2nd 2016 the day she
disappeared
to pick her up
and uh apparently this was engineered
ahead of time because she was out on her
morning jog and then she got in the car
with him according to him
and she left her phone there for
evidence
he says that she slept most of the drive
back um you know
back of her car slept all the way back
to his house in southern california
so basically he says that she stayed at
his apartment
for all the weeks that she was gone
she wouldn't eat very much
uh she cut her own hair because remember
when i said when they found her her hair
was all [ __ ] up
he says toward the end of the stay um he
asked her to brand her asked him to
brand her
with a like a crafting tool that they
bought at hobby lobby
uh so there was that
he also says
uh he
drove her back toward reading and
dropped her off where she said to drop
her off
so she apparently engineered this whole
thing
um
so because of this interview like the
cops
uh you know got all the cell phone
records from this time period
this apparently corroborates his story
um
the two of them were using prepaid
phones to communicate back and forth
so that there wouldn't be a record but
as far as i know they can still like
track that down if they know what
they're doing
because it's still out there somewhere
uh so this affidavit also says
the family
this is [ __ ] up so the family had
started to go fund me
um because she was missing they thought
she was missing legit they thought she'd
been kidnapped
and this gofundme raised more than 49
000
oh [ __ ]
um was that the motive
see i'm well okay it might have been
monetary but it might have been
allegedly i don't know
but a lot of people they interviewed
about her like after this whole kind of
thing broke was that she was very like
attention seeking so it might have been
like for monetary gain like as a
secondary but i kind of feel like maybe
she's one of those people that needs to
be the center of attention all the time
so it might be that so it's like i
because they said even before she was
trying to make money on the [ __ ] she was
always kind of saying how she was abused
as a child and she was this that the
other she was always like being
right yeah so she always kind of had
that thing where she had to be
you know she was star first he's a
[ __ ] artist yeah
so there was that so yeah so the
gofundme made like 49 000
and that ended up paying
a bunch of like the papini's credit card
bills and quote-unquote personal
expenses
um also the fbi investigators who are
looking into this case they also said
that sherry actually applied for and got
more than 30 000
from the california victim compensation
board
and that she actually ended up using
that money
to buy
like therapy for herself and like new
like venetian blinds for her house and
[ __ ] like that
so
that's some [ __ ] right there because
like somebody
who actually needed that money could
have used that money and then this [ __ ]
[ __ ] used it so at this point the fbi
are kind of like okay well this woman
obviously engineered this whole stunt
to
make money and to draw attention to
herself you know in i don't know if in
that order or in a different order
um but her family it must be said have
denied the allegations as they would i
don't know allegedly like i said it's
all like still under investigation
um
her family came out and said we love
sherry and are appalled by the way in
which law enforcement ambush ambushed
her uh that afternoon like the day that
they caught her in a dramatic and
unnecessary manner in front of her
children so they got like kind of
outraged about it but i will say march
9th
2022 which was only a couple of weeks
ago as we're live streaming
um
papini they actually did arrest her like
on charges of of [ __ ] but on march 9th
they released her from jail before her
trial because she is going to stand
trial
uh for
mail fraud and lying to a federal
officer because they think that her
whole deal
was engineered in order to make money or
again just to like draw attention to
herself so she was put in jail for a
short time she was arrested she is going
to stand trial
um but she was released on march uh
ninth
uh on a hundred and twenty thousand
dollar bond
uh and she had to surrender her passport
so she can go anyplace
um
she didn't have any comment her lawyer
didn't have any comment so her trial is
pending
uh so but yeah she is probably gonna get
in big trouble for this [ __ ] stunt
that she pulled because
she i mean think of all the
resources that she used up that like
people that actually needed it could
have used
that's just it's shitty you know what i
mean if that's true that's like that's
shitty i remember when this case went
down i was thinking about it i was like
well you know that sounds kind of wild
but [ __ ] like that does happen maybe you
know they were going to sell her or
something that's what i'm saying
and that's what i mean and that's
in a way that's what makes cases like
this like makes me madder because
[ __ ] like this does happen yeah in real
life and when you pull crap like this
yeah and you fake it yeah you got paid
then you're making it harder for people
who's crazy [ __ ] like that actually does
happen to you then you're making it
harder for other people to believe that
and to get help because everyone's gonna
think you're bullshitting just like that
[ __ ] did yeah when you fake some [ __ ]
so that's like that makes it doubly
worse in my opinion when you fake some
[ __ ] like this you gotta pay
that's what i mean that's the shit's
never gotta go to jail i mean come on
like look everybody wants money we all
want that but come on god damn it it's
like that just makes me so mad and it's
just kind of like buddying the waters
that's what you're [ __ ] other people
over yeah
and probably you don't think about it
like that because you're like
self-centered but yeah you're [ __ ]
other people over like people whose bad
[ __ ] happens to them and they and
maybe that's like a crazy [ __ ] story
yeah like that and now you come forward
with it and no one's gonna believe you
because of this [ __ ] and then you're
coming you're coming out and going well
you know those mexicans did it
with [ __ ] now you're [ __ ] making the
mexicans look bad on on the back of
something you just [ __ ] made up right
that's what i mean that was just like
that [ __ ] that drowned her own kids in
the car and then said two black men yeah
the blacks did it yeah
man don't do that [ __ ] come on yeah when
you said that maybe think of shatner
why
because shat said his he found his wife
oh that's right crown in the damn pool
we should do a show about that
i don't think shaq killed her but he
didn't sound legit [ __ ] when he was
calling the cops
i found her he found his
his wife floating in a damn pool
that's right i had forgotten about that
yes that's something and uh they were
having problems
but a lot of couples that have been
together for a long time are having
problems but that's what i mean you
can't really like when somebody dies
like in a way that looks accidental yeah
i mean obviously i know the cops have to
look at every single thing but like you
said couples any couple that's been
together for that long anything longer
than five six years right you're gonna
have problems everybody has problems
we're humans yeah so
you know yeah you have to look into that
but you can't like
lean too much on that either because
that doesn't necessarily mean that
you're gonna kill a [ __ ]
wouldn't that be a trip if shat [ __ ]
killed his wife
we were talking about that the other day
we were talking about that the other day
we were in the car the other day and we
had i don't know how we got on the
subject but we were talking about that
case like what would happen if what
happened if it turned out [ __ ] did it
kills what if he actually did yeah
allegedly yeah
i mean she did die in the pool but like
i said people do drown accidentally like
[ __ ] happens
there's no evidence i mean i leaned more
towards he didn't have anything to do
with it i mean it might have just been
you know maybe she you know was drunk or
maybe she was on the driveway
she was into alcohols and pills and it
was california you know they're partiers
he had a [ __ ] pool out in the back
[Applause]
you know it's plausible that it was an
accident
that's what i mean
don't know you don't know i i you know
i'm gonna give shad the benefit of the
doubt he didn't have anything to do with
it
you know yeah and to tell more evidence
well it's one of those things where and
i think we've talked about this on a few
cases i think we talked about this on
like the madame madeleine mccann show
and stuff like that and i kind of feel
like there's a thing too where
especially like when a child disappears
or gets killed
everybody's first instinct is to like
demonize the parents for whatever reason
just like when somebody
dies that's buried to somebody famous
and it's like everyone's gonna demonize
the husband or wife or whatever but it's
kind of like
unless it looks legit like somebody's
actually murdered i'm reserving judgment
you know what i mean because accidents
do happen now james said wasn't like the
third wife yeah probably was but you
know he's hollywood that's how they were
you know
yeah and like yeah that's sketch but
it's like that's kind of like not that
weird like it's hollywood i mean
hollywood marriages tend not to last
because they're just dating
yes
well they don't last because you're not
together a lot i mean you're usually
working like in other parts of the
country you're to get you're like apart
for like months at a time so now my
friend khan of oslon not his real name
but that he is his title he is the khan
of ozlon
the the nation that will probably soon
appear one day once once the people get
their [ __ ] land back okay and the
union is dissolved
but he says well i'm just saying the
third world is all about [ __ ] people
over for the most part just saying if
you're gonna
walk the walk you better [ __ ] talk
the talk because here you get your ass
torched
i agree
okay
whatever
i don't really know exactly what you're
talking about khan but uh i'm gonna go
ahead and agree with you that's the way
it is now i didn't know exactly he's
talking about i don't know what he's
referring to but uh yeah my time in
brazil will [ __ ] tell you that that
yeah that's the way it is
but you know what i mean these uh
tenderfoot north americans are not yet
[ __ ] fully fully [ __ ] informed
about that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
if if you're gonna talk to talk you
better [ __ ]
understand how to walk the walk
that's true yeah but i'm just saying you
can't like jump jump to conclusions
either right just because something if
something looks like an accident
right
unless there's a lot of motive behind
there
more than oh they were having problems
because like i said that's that's now
rebecca says most hollywood marriages
don't last because they're arranged
marriages for promotion within
management fact
i i doubt it i'd have to [ __ ] well i
kind of feel like that might have been
more the case back in the day back in
the day like especially when they were
trying to cover up the gay
uh yeah i mean it's like well we don't
want this actor like everybody like
they're all these rumors that he's gay
so we have to like marry him off to
somebody um one of our subscribers here
who's a regular he's never on here live
but he always gets back with me after
the show with brian
and
brian and i came up military school
together and he's done he works in
hollywood and done a lot of movies okay
and um you know he did [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] the vfw did [ __ ] gina
carano flicks uh did that last shut in
uh he uh done a lot of [ __ ] cool
movies did [ __ ] um
uh [ __ ] the one with crosstalk the
one with the cannibals what was that
called bone tomahawk bone tomahawk
i'd have to ask him about it but he
hasn't mentioned anything about arranged
marriages i would tend to think that
[ __ ] for the most part
hollywood people marry each other upon
impulse you're dealing with stars
there's a lot of ego involved
and uh they're on top
they may at the time be on top of a
[ __ ] wave like tom cruise would do
he's done he's number one so he marries
a female number one
and they [ __ ] live the high life for
a few years and they realize that
they're really just normal people and
they got all kinds of problems and the
fantasy starts
and
yeah they're not superhuman they're not
just regular [ __ ] people you gotta
boop and fart like right
in fact not only they just regular
people in some ways i think they have a
lot more problems than regular people
have
because they can't live a normal life um
and they i could see that would and
honestly like look i have a lot of
problems but i can see how that would be
that would not i would not like to live
like that now luckily luckily the
society has changed because movies
aren't as cool as they were they're cool
some of them are cool most of them suck
even though they always
most of them sucked only summer but
there's but the thing about nowadays is
that there's so many other options right
are entertainment they have a lot
there's a lot of there's a lot of
competition which they didn't have back
in the old days they don't even really
have movie stars as me and jenny knew
them and some of you older people who
are our age know they don't even really
have those anymore the closest thing to
a movie star today
would be who
from the younger generation thank you
zach
what jet was zack saying the most
successful hollywood marriage i know of
is paul newman and joanne woodward yeah
they were married
forever yeah holy crap
i would think uh
oh [ __ ]
for me the closest thing to a movie star
would be dude [ __ ] started in [ __ ]
um uh uh fury road and all those other
movies though
tom hardy
tom hardy's kind of a movie star
all right i mean there's people that are
like
rock is a movie star like universally
recognizable yeah there is that yeah the
rock is a movie star
um
[Music]
jennifer lawrence yeah yeah yeah right
like most people like be like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah we know who that is the
rest of them are just working actors
really and that's wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with that they
just kind of come and go and they're
doing they're making their money daniel
craig daniel craig he's kind of he's a
movie star
they're just there's not as many people
that everybody knows who they are i kind
of feel like yes even if you don't
follow movies you know who that picture
there's not as many movie stars as they
were and movie stars aren't as cool or
pro
okay
prolific as they used to be when we were
kids they are ubiquitous
there's so many other right
forms of meeting right
i mean
here's the [ __ ] thing that will piss
us the movie stars we talked about that
pissed them off there are instagram
girls that for me
are as good as a movie star
because i look at them as much as i
would look at a movie star it's they're
offering a different thing culture's
different a lot
there are youtubers
that for me
are
equal or better than a movie to me i
would be like more squeeze to like meet
like some youtubers yeah
like we talked about razor fist earlier
on [ __ ] for me i'd i'd rather meet
razer fist than a lot of movie stars or
they'd be the same if i got to hang out
with like matt and craig from welcome to
the basement yeah then that'd be right
then that would be like super awesome
and um i'd be way more excited
now on the back of that and i'm old
right and on the back of that
me and jenny grew up in a movie star
culture on the back of that those big
studios would hate to hear that that's
not what they want to hear
but they've lost that monopoly on cool a
person could just be cool based upon
their
material that they're making and putting
out in in the in in the internet that's
cool though yeah that's much cooler
that's more naturalistic
like
rock stars are gone
they're gone
except the old ones that are still
around like for me a rock star the
[ __ ]
uh you know [ __ ]
judas priest you know what i mean
[ __ ] um uh
rob halford from judas priest is a rock
star but there aren't any new rock stars
per se
other than locals like
our friends from starry night
we hang out with them well like i said
everything
on the right it's more like i don't want
to say localized because it's bigger but
it is more it's more localized now in
the sense that
not so much localized as location but
like localized in like uh you know
little kind of sub genres yeah the
starry night comes into town they put on
a show it's a tiny show compared to the
[ __ ] the old
70s and 80s everybody in town shows up
yeah everybody everybody all our friends
show up and yeah it's not they're not
filling up a coliseum like this is the
only time we come out all year it's kind
of like
we saw we saw a couple of our friends
there we haven't seen it like right
several years it's very different it's
not like it was back in the day where
queens showed up and they'd fill up a
[ __ ] coliseum
you know it was a different scene
they had more of a mountain there was
kind of less avenues yeah to success
right now there's more like you don't
get as successful like you're not going
to make fun of me
bajillion no one has a monopoly right
democratized yeah but there's more
tentacles right
uh you're gonna make less but at least
you have like your own audience right
what i was gonna say is that when like
talking about youtubers you guys know
how much we love dan bell yeah um dan
bell what he started doing he does a
live stream every saturday night in case
you guys didn't know
and he drives around baltimore sometimes
he does like rando nautica he does uh a
band like abandoned places ghost hunts
he does different stuff
what he started doing was that he
started doing a drawing of all his
patrons of which there are many he has
hundreds of patrons
so he does a drawing of
if somebody wants to come with him on
the saturday night thing so if you can
be in baltimore where he lives
and on that saturday night in particular
and you want to like win the thing you
can enter and he does that so every week
for the past couple months he's been
doing these saturday things with like so
it's a different person like a fan like
every time and it's hilarious because
you have like it's kind of cool because
you see him and he's awesome but it's
like you have this random person that's
just like a fan of his or her patron
and it's a different person every time
and like their whole family is watching
and it's just kind of like they're kind
of like so excited like to meet danny's
like he's like this big [ __ ]
celebrity yeah and it's like he's a
youtuber yeah but
i mean he's got like millions of [ __ ]
subscribers so
it's kind of like the same so he's kind
of like a celebrity in his own right so
i love that like there's just random
people like showing up being like hey
i'm like look i'm famous i'm like on the
[ __ ] youtube show with dan all right
conor watson's coming back explaining
what he was talking about
for those who don't know khan
khan is a friend of mine we talk on uh
messenger all the time
uh he lives in tijuana he's got a cute
wife and he's got two sons that look
like they should be in goddamn hollywood
okay they look like you know they look
like a little a little mexican tom
cruise and and [ __ ] uh
they just look like little he his sons
look like movie stars okay this is what
he was talking about he says the
reference is if you're going to do bad
[ __ ] to people you better be prepared
because
because if it if not if it plays out
your ass is gonna
gonna be dragged across the street and
eventually burn in the middle of the
town
the laws in mexico's are for the rich
people uh it is the laws of mexico are
for the rich he's talking about the
disintegration of [ __ ] civil society
over the whole world right now really
and he goes people are now enforcing
what he called
uh mako how to i'm not sure how to
pronounce it
yeah yeah
and in some rural towns way up in the
mountains
their asses get eaten no joke this is
something that
a lot of people in the north can't
accept
traditional mexico were cannibals okay
you got your ass eaten it was well i
would eat you too if you pissed me off
yeah right right okay so i get it which
it makes a lot of sense if you
understand the geography of mexico and
what kind of animals they had and the
dietary constraints that were played you
got your ass eaten okay
and their religion uh the old the old uh
nahal [ __ ] mexican religion
uh
it's so basic
good deeds
live a peaceful life bad actions the
reapers will eventually get you exactly
just be cool everybody god damn yeah now
zach [ __ ] said super chat at five
dollars
saying there's something so weird about
watching a real old movie finding the
actress hot and then realizing oh you're
dead now yeah yeah we've all had that
yeah cause i'm real i love silent movies
and so i watch like all the silent like
old silent movies like uh you know all
the [ __ ] the phantom carriage and
like the hands of
the hands of orlac and all that kind of
stuff and it's just kind of like man
this is so cool and like everybody looks
so cool and i'm like oh they're dead
yeah
that's so creepy no but that makes the
movies better in my opinion oh boy a
murder hornet who lives on the border
who always goes to mexico all the time
as a friend of mine i say what only
matters in mexico is money that's not
true that's not what matters in mexico
what matters in mexico is the same thing
that matters everywhere
power
power is what really matters yeah about
money
sometimes money is power sometimes
violence is power but really
truth is not a reality truth even
doesn't matter what matters is power
because if you have power you can
dictate truth to people and you can
dictate
justice to people and that's that's the
nature of power
and all of the mesoamerican societies
and cultures were really hinged upon
power
religious power
or just you know
power
but you know they're all like that all
societies are like that power is central
kelly g's talking about kurt and goldie
yeah i love you yeah yeah
and i love that they were in christmas
chronicles together that is so [ __ ]
cute yeah that they were saying
christmas chronicles
christmas chronicles one on netflix is a
masterpiece two is good it's okay but
christmas chronicles one yeah the second
one was like all right but the first one
was like way way better i'm hoping that
there's gonna be a third one
i mean probably i kind of feel like they
probably won't make a third one oh
[ __ ] uh crossover at least the second
one had bells nickel in it which i was
kind of i was into that like how they
went into that like old christmas
mythology i was like all right i see
what you're doing kurt russell makes a
good santa claus
real good yeah cause he's like cranky
but he's like just the right amount of
cranky
well he's kind of macho too for an old
guy right and uh he but he's fun
he's fun he's he's a good natured guy
we watched christmas chronicles the
first one every christmas and brian
brian who i mentioned before uh worked
on several films with uh kurt russell
and he says kurt russell is at it's
exactly as he appears he's the kind of
guy you would want to hang out with he's
a good guy he's the kind of guy you go
to his farm and ride around
four-wheelers and shoot guns and talk
about old west [ __ ]
guns and [ __ ] like that he's just you
know
he's a guy guy he's gonna see like i
said
honestly whatever your proclivities are
whatever your whatever is
i just like people that are just
themselves yeah he's just himself don't
try to be something that you're not if
you're just as long as you're not like
an obnoxious ass like that's something
else but if you're just like a cool
person
and you just like act like how you are
you're not pretending to be something
else then that's awesome quentin
tarantino liked him
me and quentin tarantino went to middle
school together i feel like nobody
doesn't like kurt runs who doesn't like
her russell yeah
i can't think of a single person me and
quentin tarantino went to dominguez
elementary school in california together
i remember him but i thought he was in
the same grade as me
he wasn't he was a couple years older
than me but i remember yeah i looked
that up later yeah it's like that i
think he was a year or two older than me
he ended up working at the uh
at the uh the video the video store just
up the street yeah from uh in carson
where used to live over here near the
mexican restaurant where my dad used to
love that basket restaurant it's called
english called el ranchitos i think is
what it was called
and then uh behind that area in the
[ __ ] um
in the uh uh commercial
rental areas that's where um
oh what's his name [ __ ] had his damn
motorcycle shop not billy lane the other
one one that was [ __ ] married to um
oh that guy oh
what's his name
james jesse james yeah yeah i was like
famous guy's name famous jesse james
motorcycle studio was in the place where
we used to [ __ ] jump the fence and go
play out in the damn strawberry fields
owned by the japanese dudes the japanese
dudes would be out there on the [ __ ]
strawberry fields and then behind that
was the stables that i used to ride my
horses at or my ponies that my mom used
to [ __ ] she my mom had her horse there
and i had my pony there
and christina toy and her dad owned that
farm and um christina's dad was japanese
and uh christina was half japanese that
was a japanese area
a lot of people don't know that
but california was like been colonized
by the japanese
for a long time a lot of them ended up
going back to japan though and what they
did was is they grew strawberries they
grew strawberries and had little farms
and they made wine
a lot of that california wine everybody
was talking about like this [ __ ]
famous california you know and they have
[ __ ] what's that old fat dude's name
orson welles out there talking about his
what was it all new yeah it was still
not why before his time and they had all
these [ __ ] famous [ __ ] fancy
french and [ __ ] italian sounding
names and [ __ ] that was japanese wine
it was japanese guys that owned those
companies
california company well as i said
there's marketing always a lot more
marketing
yeah marketing is marketing yeah you
know it's a whole different thing yeah
but you know it's fun i had a huge crush
on christina toy
i showed pictures of it i got pictures
over my military school [ __ ]
yearbooks you got a crush on everybody
yeah without the way i was i was
i was sensitive yourself i was sensitive
yeah i fall in love with all these girls
not anymore
yeah and i'm still sensitive i'm old now
though it's it's you're just sensitive
anymore well no it is as you get older
we got into the whole nihilism
discussion
that's the way you don't care about
anything you know it's just what you're
waiting into here it's what you read
into as you get older at least in my in
at least i did as i got older i
appreciated you
human
physiology human beauty and human
strength more
as i went there was something about me
watching my dad almost die
it changed me that health and beauty was
far more important than i thought
because it's so temporary it's fleeting
because it's temporary i see it as less
important i'm kind of like more
interested in people's
like what like their inner kind of [ __ ]
well it's holistic it's everything at
once that's what i mean it's holistic
it's everything it was
i'm not as interested in people's like
physical appearance because that's
because that changes over time so it's
not that interesting to me i'm more
interested in people's what are their
philosophies what are their dreams what
are their i'm more interested in like
their inner [ __ ] i see it as all one
thing
i mean it is to an extent right but to
me
what's going on with your inner self
that's more important to me than what's
going on with your outer self because
like i said that's not
it's that's very changeable you can
change that
uh you know you can change it through
surgery or whatever
um and when you get old it changes so
i'm not as interested in that because
it's not it's fleeting so i don't really
care about it i care about like what is
going on with you as a person
you know what i mean yeah out outside of
like this yeah i know what you mean i
don't really agree but i understand
yeah but that that's why it's not
important to me because it's not i
believe in a holistic approach
more greek i mean well like i said i
think we we're both talking about the
same thing i'm just it's just like a
percentage issue yeah i'm kind of like
physical to me is more like maybe 10 or
20 percent oh no for me it's 50 and like
to me it's like more like i'm more
interested in like what's going on like
inside your mind and body fit is 50
percent i'm more i understand what's
going on
so there's that okay
so all right so i got a couple more
cases
now this was the case i didn't actually
okay now this was the case we talked
about
um back on episode 225
uh early december 2020
and this was a very fake
very very famous case because there were
cctv
videos of this kid
uh disappearing
this is andrew gosden
and i didn't realize that there had been
some updates in this case until
somebody sent me an update on it
uh so i wanted to talk about this so
just to remind everybody
um okay so this kid was born in 1993
he's from south yorkshire this is a
british case
and he was basically when he was a kid
um
kind of a shy kid kind of introverted
but
very intelligent
very mature for his age
um
very gifted
uh and also at school he had 100 percent
attendance
and he was in the gifted program he was
real into like video games really into
like heavy metal and [ __ ] like that
so september 14 2007
uh at which point andrew was 14 years
old
so he wakes up for school that day like
he did usually but his mom noticed on
this particular day
that he was really like kind of cranky
on this day and he had like slept late
which was unlike him because he was very
he liked school and he was uh always on
time and was always like kind of
interested in going to school so she
thought it was like weird that he was
acting a little bit different that he
was like kind of like irritable and
stuff
so he gets ready to go to school and
leaves the house
at five minutes past eight in the
morning
he gets uh seen by a family friend
sitting by his usual bus stop
but apparently what happened
was that instead of getting on this bus
which would have taken him to school
he actually let the bus go by and sat on
the bench
and waited
now what they think he was waiting for
was that he was just waiting there
for his uh parents and stuff to leave
his house so he could go back to his
house because indeed that's what
happened
according to his neighbor's cctv camera
he actually came back to his house at 8
30 in the morning
changed out of his school uniform
and put on his own clothes
which was you know dark jeans
his backpack and a slipknot t-shirt
and at this point he takes his wallet
his keys and his psp
playstation console
so he leaves his house again about 8 30
in the morning
and he goes to doncaster train station
on the way there
he stops at an atm
and he takes out
200 pounds
from his account
he goes to the station and buys a
one-way ticket
to london
now the woman that is the selling the
tickets
she says well you can buy a return for
just 50 pence more
and he's very adamant at saying no i
just won a one-way
which she thought was very unusual and
she remembered later on
um interestingly even though he took 200
pounds out of his bank account
he actually left a hundred pounds cash
of birthday money
uh at his house he didn't take that with
him
so uh all the witness accounts say that
they saw
uh this kid
boarding the train to king's cross
station at 9 35 in the morning
by himself
and at this point
andrew's school had noticed that he was
not in his morning classes
so they tried to call his parents to ask
where he was
unfortunately
they called
the wrong number
and left a message at the wrong number
so his parents didn't know until later
11 20 am
the train arrives at king's cross
and the cctv camera very famously
caught the last confirmed sighting of
andrew gosden he was leading the station
it's very very famous if you know
anything about true crime and you
followed like missing person stuff
you've seen like the video of this kid
leaving king's cross station and then he
disappeared and they have no idea where
he went to
uh so he left the station 11 25 am and
that was the last time he was ever seen
at this train station
so that night andrew's family come home
and they didn't immediately twig to the
fact that andrew was missing because
they thought oh well he's just up in his
room playing video games or listening to
music like he usually did so they didn't
like really check on him
um so basically they noticed he wasn't
there like an hour or two later
and then they started calling around to
uh you know his friends and [ __ ] like
that
um he didn't have a cell phone at the
time
because
they said that his family said well we
would buy him them and did like buy him
cell phones and he would lose them so we
just stopped buying them so he didn't
have one
um so
they called the cops at this point
because they're just like they don't
know where he is
um so at this point they start searching
the local area
uh they make a missing person's poster
and like kind of put that around
several days later a woman comes forward
and says i'm the person that sold andrew
the train ticket uh at the king's cross
station
and said i remembered him because i told
him you can buy a return ticket for just
50 pence more and he was very adamant
that he did not want that he just won it
one way um
so
they asked his dad kevin about this and
he said well that's not that weird
because
um he had a lot of friends in london
that he could have stayed with overnight
um so
it wasn't that strange that maybe he
just like went to london decided he was
going to stay with somebody overnight
and come back the next day
uh they did a search of several other
areas where
he had friends or relatives but they
didn't find anything
now what they thought at first the cops
was that andrew had gone to london to
meet somebody specifically because it
did seem like
he had deliberately
like lied to his parents skipped school
and then deliberately taken the train to
london one-way ticket so he it looked
like he was going to meet somebody like
on purpose
and like i said they knew he was doing
it because they caught him on the cctv
camera
but the thing about it uh so they
thought well maybe he met somebody on
the internet and he was like going to
meet them
however
um the thing about it this is like
this is weird but like he didn't really
use the computer all that much he didn't
have an email address
[ __ ] like that it's not impossible that
he met somebody in the internet but it
just seems like unlikely
um they also
uh the cops looked into uh andrew's uh
playstation to see if he had
access social media on that but they
didn't find anything
so they didn't really know why thank you
david june good evening everyone just
got in the room hope everyone is doing
well thank you damn david you late ma'am
i mean you know yeah we're still going i
still had a couple cases yeah we start
we started late at the new time of six
so yeah we started at six so we haven't
been going on we've been going two hours
and 50 minutes and an hour of it was
introduction
that's true well lately as usual yeah
yeah
so
yeah at this point like the cops are
just kind of like okay like we don't
know what happened then because it's
just kind of like
his family and his friends said well he
wouldn't have just taken off to go
sightseeing or some [ __ ] like that now
one of the things that they thought he
might have done though and this sounds
kind of likely
he was real into he was only 14. he was
real into heavy metal
now
the night the day that he disappeared
there was a gig that night
um
it was 30 seconds to mars at brixton
academy
and there was a metal band called sixth
and they were playing at the carling
academy and that was only
like a block away from the king's cross
station so it could have been that he
didn't really want to ask his parents to
go to the show
and he's like [ __ ] it i'm just going to
the show anyway and then he just went to
it without telling them so it's possible
that that happened
now uh so it could have been that and
his dad kind of believed that he said
his quote was
um
that his son might have gone to london
to quote do something for which he felt
it was easier to seek forgiveness
for rather than permission
so maybe he wanted to go to a gig and he
didn't want to ask his because he's only
14.
and he knew he knew they would have said
no so you know so he's like well i'm
just going to go and
then come back and later
um and so they thought maybe it was like
spur of the moment
now there was a lot of controversy about
this case at the time because
even though like his parents obviously
like reported him missing pretty much
immediately like the cops really didn't
i don't think they didn't think to or
they didn't really care to look at the
cctv footage from all of the stuff so
the cctv footage that's very famous from
this case the andrew gosden case um
they didn't really find that until like
a month later like finding him coming
out of the station so there was that uh
there were also some witness reports
that placed him in a pizza hut nearby
and also a
sighting of him at covent garden
and uh they actually the cops didn't
actually talk to the witness that had
seen him in kindergarten for like six
weeks after he disappeared
and some people said that these leads
were never even followed up on
um so at this point like some people are
thinking because he still he never
turned up afterward obviously
uh so some people are starting to think
that maybe he got murdered
10 months after he disappeared um there
was another 16 year old boy who actually
went missing from enfield which is a
suburb of manchester i believe
and uh he was going to a friend's house
and he disappeared and some people think
that maybe that kid got like kidnapped
and maybe like
human trafficking something like that
and that maybe the same people
did the same [ __ ] so we'll see
um
but
the thing about it if he ran away it did
seem like his initial
leaving
was deliberate
he did deliberately go to his bus stop
he did deliberately miss his bus
he did deliberately go back to the house
and change his clothes
and take money out of the account and
get a one-way ticket to london so
obviously he was going there for a
reason he didn't take the money from
his birthday he had 100 pounds in his
room which was not taken
people also noted that he didn't take a
coat
he didn't take he took his psp but he
didn't take the charger
um he didn't take anything that would
indicate that he was going away for a
long time is what i'm saying
um you know so he seemed like he went
away but not
that he was gonna be gone for an
extended period of time
um
nobody said that he was uh exhibiting
any signs of depression or anything like
that so nobody thinks he went off to
like kill himself or whatever
now to this day like today he would be
late 20s
now in early december of 2021 not that
long ago
the west midlands police
said that they had arrested two men
in uh conjunction with this case
one of them was a 45 year old man one of
them was a 38 year old man
they think that both of these men
uh they're suspected of kidnapping
and human trafficking and the 45 year
old is also charged with possession of
indecent images of children
so
we're kind of thinking that maybe uh
andrew gosden
was either
i don't know if somebody approached him
online or somebody approached him in
person or somebody found him like maybe
he actually did go to the gig like he
said he was gonna do
and then these two dudes
somehow like got their clutches into him
but they arrested these two dudes
and these two dudes are suspected
of
trafficking children
for
uh nefarious purposes how old was this
victim again 14
14.
now the photographs that they had there
are boys or girls
i don't know
that's kind of an important detail
they're not telling us
well i mean they might but i i didn't
see it but you know just in the
[ __ ] that i did i don't know i just
can't comment on it i guess i mean like
i said
it does seem like the kid went away on
purpose
but
from all the evidence it seems like he
wasn't planning to be away all that long
like i said he didn't bring the charger
for his playstation he didn't bring that
extra 100 pounds he didn't bring i think
that he was just going to london for
that show
and didn't want to tell his parents so
he just like skipped school and he's
like well i'll just skip out to the show
and then like come back and then while
he was in london he met with
some
yeah well difficult something happened
something bad happened to him because he
never came back i'm questioning it
i don't know it does happen though it
does happen
14 kind of sometimes hard to deal with
and
i'd have to know that the supposed
offenders
better
you know i mean you had dean carl doing
[ __ ] to do to dudes that were older than
that
but his motive was a lot different well
you just have there's not enough
information there yeah
i'm just saying that two arrests have
been made
and it's like
older dudes that have been arrested for
human trafficking and allegedly child
porn
type of charges
and they have been arrested in
conjunction with this case
so obviously they think that there is
some connection
uh they're not really saying what it is
there's not enough information because
that's what they do yeah um and they've
released them for now but they're still
keeping them under surveillance because
they must have been there wasn't enough
to hold them
well well it's the uk so it's different
i don't know if like the laws might be
slightly different but they do kind of
like
they got you they got you they do
suspect that these two dudes had
something to do with this kid's
disappearance
or at least they did for a while if they
got you they got you they don't let you
go
well the thing i'd have to look at the
details of the [ __ ] british laws but
uh you know
uh i don't know i mean something else
could have happened to this kid
well a lot of things could have happened
to this kid which is sad because i mean
this kid looks like he's cute as a
button he's like a little 14 year old
little kid with little glasses
was his little slipknot shirt never
found a body nope
he just he he he may have been abducted
and then murdered
something happened to him i don't think
i think that he went away
that day
on purpose but i think he was just going
like i said to a gig or
to do something that he wasn't supposed
to do like he thought he'd get in
trouble i don't think he thought that he
was gonna be gone for that long i don't
think he was running away from home or
anything like that like i said he didn't
take his [ __ ] charger he didn't take
extra money he didn't take anything like
that he didn't take a coat he didn't
take anything that you would think that
you would need if you're gonna be gone
for an extended period of time i think
that he was just going to that event
or something and he thought he was going
to be back like the next day
i think i think yeah that's what it
sounds like something happened to him
and i think that when he got there
something happened to him something
happened to him there's not enough there
for me to give an opinion and that's he
met with some [ __ ] yeah yeah there's
no talent you just they're just got to
wait till and it's really sad but like i
said more comes out i mean
jenny and i have been doing this for a
while
and she's written entire books at it
there's [ __ ] that's happened [ __ ]
hundreds hundreds of years ago 100 years
ago
not much information and nothing more
ever emerged you would be amazed at the
amount of people that just kind of
disappear
and that's it it's kind of sad when you
think about it and like i said if you
ever want to be like [ __ ] depressed
yeah
for a day go to wikipedia and go to like
unsolved murders or like unidentified
murder victims yeah well there's so many
now's the time to plug one of your books
so you [ __ ] detail the [ __ ] from the
unseen hand
there's a lot of that [ __ ] well no
that's the poltergeist book oh no no no
faceless bill face the villain oh you
know what you should do yeah i actually
have three print copies of that because
i bought them for somebody that wanted
signed copies go in that closet and get
them so i can show them online they're
in that closet right there they're like
little box right there
yeah i wrote like three whole [ __ ]
books
about
unsolved murders some of these have been
solved and i'm gonna talk about that in
a minute because one of them actually
has been solved but
you still sign copies
yeah somebody asked for them so i
ordered some copies this is the first
volume
right there
it's already signed ready to go well i
haven't signed it yes you're good but
yeah i'm wait until they send me the
money okay but um this is volume two
which is the biggest one
because this is
yeah
it's a big thick books people she
researched the [ __ ] out of these
assistants
at night
jenny can [ __ ] write a book telling
you
yeah
few [ __ ] volumes of this [ __ ] yeah
yeah and
all the cases that are in here hundreds
and hundreds yeah um that is just like a
tiny like [ __ ] drop in the bucket of
how many are out there i had to leave
out so many
i didn't leave out so many i only put in
the ones in the book that were
weird like random like i said i left out
like gang stuff like
robberies right political assassinations
because i said well it if we don't know
who did that we'll like we at least know
what the motive is right i was more
interested in stuff that was like
motive-less like why the [ __ ] would
somebody do that i was more interested
in that kind of [ __ ] just find a house
and it's [ __ ] people but and there's
like yeah and it's like nothing's taken
or anything like that i'm more
interested in that kind of like why
right so
and even with that there was that many
[ __ ] cases yeah even and that's that
and there was more than that and there
was more than that i had to like leave
out a bunch of [ __ ]
because i couldn't find enough
information or whatever that was just
like
here's the weird
and [ __ ]
i guess you can say unhappy truth
you can kill somebody and get away with
it
as long as you're not connected to that
person
yeah and we've said this before like on
some of the cases and like like i said
i'm not giving anybody advice or
anything like that but and it's much
harder to get away with nowadays now
that we have dna proof and cameras
everywhere cameras everywhere dna
profile like
i'm gonna say like if you're alive about
if you could get a time machine back to
the 70s then you could probably get away
even more or 90s yeah yeah nowadays
you probably wouldn't get away it's a
lot harder it's a lot harder
but
honestly what they say is like you you
just have to kill people that are like
not uh that don't have any connection to
you
as long as it's kind of random
because that's where they have to start
yeah is people that are like because no
well and you know why they do that
because
90 90 95 percent of the time
the person that kills you is gonna be
some [ __ ] that knows you right
usually intimately luckily even most
even most psycho [ __ ] don't
kill random people
most people that kill somebody kill
somebody that they know for a reason
yeah and i mean right that's bad but
at least those [ __ ] mostly get
caught
yeah
so i'm saying that like people are well
people worry about serial killers i'm
not saying that you shouldn't i'm just
saying that
being killed by a random person it could
happen
it happens all the time but
statistically it's yeah it's it's very
unlikely if someone's gonna murder you
it's probably somebody that you know
yeah you should be more worried about
people that you know than random ass
[ __ ] yeah and they're killing
you for a reason and they're killing you
for whether that reason is legit or not
no that's a whole different issue it's a
reason that you probably know about a
lot of yeah half the time it's some kind
of an argument [ __ ] i was just watching
i was watching one of this bizarre
murder show last night and in this case
this woman turned up dead
and her pieces
were found in suitcases all like in
these parks like her torso and her arms
and
her legs and her head was like found in
these different suitcases and it turned
out like they had all these other
suspects but it found it turned out that
like her brother had done it
yeah allegedly i don't know if this is
true or not this is the brothers story
the brother said oh they got an argument
and like he like whacked her in the head
because he was mad
and he killed her and he didn't mean to
and then because he didn't mean to kill
her he decided to compound his error by
cutting her body up
and then putting it in
various suitcases and like dumping in a
park which
i find that very hard to believe look
if you kill somebody accidentally i
understand like you would panic and [ __ ]
like that
but
then to say
to to jump from that to i'm gonna cut
this body into pieces
and very
methodically place the pieces into
different suitcases
and dump them at various times and
places at this park
i am not buying that i kind of feel like
that was
yeah i'm not buying that dude's story
all right they're asking me questions
about the shirt all right you missed the
beginning part of the show
all right i gotta pee again this was a
this shirt was from a band called
laboratory it was the opening act to the
story night show that we saw a couple
days back
and in laboratory it's two girls and a
dude and it's kind of like cam fdm and
there was a [ __ ]
little chick she's probably
five feet tall 411 or something [ __ ]
skinny with a big booty and she comes up
out of a dab
coughing and with [ __ ]
glowing contact lenses and starts
singing and she was like right there in
front of me and after the show
i bought the shirt
name of the band is called laboratory
and it was the
[ __ ] ugliest shirt i've ever seen but
it's you're right it's like a rorschach
test
it's damn hand
i don't know who drew this [ __ ] it's a
hand with [ __ ] strings like a puppet
master
going through a coffin
with some people it doesn't make any
goddamn sense i looked at it and i was
like man that's the shittiest shirt i've
ever seen i'ma buy one so i just bought
it for 20 bucks
and i bought it
uh but uh now i'm not selling this one
and uh you guys are talking about the uh
the the other shoes the plaskin shirts
and the um
and the uh
the [ __ ] uh blade runner shirts from
the genetic republicans the
regenexx
replicates
we have a [ __ ] um plans to do
uh an ocp shirt from robocop but jenny's
[ __ ] dragging her feet on it i'm not
dragging my feet i'm just busy okay
she's busy
we have i want a canon studio shirt and
i want a [ __ ] ocp
shirt uh
in about a week can you do it jenny i'll
put it on a thing and i'll i'll start
i'll make sure it's and i'll start
offering it
write it down okay i did a canon design
already the design you did this you did
the design for ocp i think already i
might have we just got to send it to you
i don't remember it was a long time ago
i just have to have like i know i did
the canon one okay
i do so much [ __ ] i like i don't even
remember
a promise [ __ ] bees nest the cannon
and the ocp shirt i do have and they
look great people i just haven't shot
but i just haven't sent the um
you know to do the training i sent it
out to get the transparency yeah we have
to go get the train and when she sends
me the transparency i'll make the
[ __ ] plate and uh and i'll make some
shirts and i'll wear it and uh i'll send
i'll send bee's nest some because now we
got to like drive a ways to the print
shop
is there a service that they can bring
i'll ride out there on the bike yeah you
can i'll ride out there on the bike
because some of the print shops like i
used to use fedex office but only
only certain fedex offices have the
transparency paper
yeah because the one nearest our house
yeah they didn't have trade they didn't
have transparency paper like half the
time so i just had to send it to like
the one farther away
so we had to drive like 10 miles to get
the book in transparency and then i had
to like bring it back and then we had to
shoot the screens in the closet and all
that kind of [ __ ] but yeah i did a canon
design i might have done an ocp i don't
remember i have to like check it out the
ocp looks good it's just like it was
from from from um
because no i i found the data file the
picture that we just got to put it on a
[ __ ]
transparency
all right it looks good it's just
straight out of the movie okay
the one that impressed me was the canon
studios
and i know you [ __ ] grew up with
those [ __ ] cheesy ass canon movies
they were great we loved them
that [ __ ] is not copyrighted canon is
long gone
and i mean i hope it's [ __ ] even
brian hackett back in hollywood i'm sure
he would love to have a [ __ ] canon
[ __ ]
shirt it would look great a white image
on a damn black shirt
and uh i'll send them out i'll send them
out we can make money on cannon
they're going to be booty
well they're not around they're not
around it's like blue legs and they see
me i feel like they maybe can't see me
they can't really suit you they're not
around i mean somebody could probably
see it it's just a cool looking logo
we're not going to print up enough of
them to be a problem and
we'll give them away or give them out
for for super chats
uh and uh we'll give we'll give them to
our subscribers
as just a bonus but it's just a good
bootleg
cool shirt
and i'll make i got just write it on
there i got it i put it on my list i got
sleeveless muscle shirts i got [ __ ]
short sleeve shirts i got women's
[ __ ] i got women's shirts yeah we
still got a closet of like stock in
there i mean i gotta like replenish it
but there's still like a lot of shirts
in there oh that we haven't printed yet
we had some titty shirts did we
yeah well because every time i order
blank shirts i or i always order like
several more than are needed yes so that
we can have like extras right so we have
a like a closet full so if you got nice
boobs we'll [ __ ] hook you up
put put that [ __ ] on a cannon shirt okay
and
your rack will be proudly displaying the
canon logo
you're like what the [ __ ] is canon you
don't know b movies if you don't know
canon you just don't know you would i
mean it was it was another era
it's just a cool logo
you saw it at the beginning of the movie
when you saw it it was a good logo like
from a graphic design standpoint it was
very it was very important yeah remember
carillo
yeah that one too no that was uh
corrupt i thought it was corel corellico
corralco
we need to get one of those too or
however they're probably long gone also
corralco
i mean like i said i'm a graphic
designer so somebody got some good logo
game i'm gonna be all into that yeah
karelco we need to get one of those you
got some good impactful [ __ ] because
like a good logo very simple
reproducible at large sizes and small
sizes looks good in black and white or
in color right you know everybody
immediately knows what that is
and it's harder to do than you think
yeah but it can't be done yeah yeah
they're asking what the shirt is i told
you these mo these are old chats well
yeah that's great wearing jenny
uh she talked about the
mary's talking about the books
yeah i told you guys what it is that's
what it was i mean i would make people a
shirt but it's like they probably can't
afford me
because i'm not working for free yeah if
you want i've done enough of that if you
want an original if you want an original
then [ __ ] you're gonna have to pay
[ __ ] i've been doing this [ __ ] for like
25 years yeah i'm past the point where
yeah and i still get this now hey can
you do this stuff for like 10 years no
no
hundreds and hundreds i mean come on
i can't pay my rent with that [ __ ]
jesus christ i'd rather like do nothing
all right so get out of the nest case uh
gaby potato okay can i get another drink
though yeah
now okay i kind of feel like
the gabby potato case
very high profile
i don't think
that we covered it on any of our regular
shows
but
do you remember there was a short time
period this was tom's idea that at the
beginning of the shows we did like a
news update segment
and i thought that we had covered the sh
covered this case on one of those but i
could be wrong about it because
when i was looking for stuff that had
been updated i was like man that sounds
really familiar i know it's really high
profile but i kind of feel like we
probably talked about it at some point
um i don't know if we did but if we
didn't i'm gonna update it anyway
because like i said this is very high
profile case
so all right gabby petito
now she was 22 years old
from long island
now she got reported missing this is
fairly recent uh september 11th
2021
uh so i feel like this might have been
in one of our news segments
when we used to do those
so she gets reported missing
during a cross-country trip with her
fiance brian laundry
in july of 2021.
now what ended up happening was that
brian
uh who was 23 a couple years older than
her or a year older than her
came home to his parents house
in florida in north port florida
without her
and so everybody thought it was a little
weird somebody like reported her missing
after that point
so what had happened prior to that
july of 2021
gabby and brian
um pack up her van
and they go on a road trip uh they were
gonna go visit all the national parks
like in one particular part of the
country
so they were in uh grand teton that was
the last place that they visited during
their van trip that summer
now
that was kind of like the last place
also that gabby was seen alive
and after that
uh thank you after that stop
was when uh brian laundry
turned up uh by himself
back in there are you eating something
mm-hmm
he got something out of the fridge
vanilla cookies
no i'm not gonna eat on camera i gotta
talk
i'll have some after well are we gonna
have like actual food after or
okay
i didn't know what you were planning
but i'm gonna see i'm see where that is
that's good
right i can cook something good now okay
i got turkey
that's right
you guys
we had a turkey
that we bought at before thanksgiving
right
before thanksgiving so we got like a
bunch of turkeys for cheek cheap and
they were frozen and our freezer has
kind of been on the fritz yeah so the
turkey started to thaw out
so tom was like dawn freeze and thawing
freezing so tom's like [ __ ] i'm gonna
cook i cook
so he cooked it so the last couple days
yeah we've been having like thanksgiving
like turkey sandwiches i didn't cook the
whole turkey i cut it into pieces and
cooked in pieces i ordered it
so we had like turkey sandwiches like
turkey and mashed potatoes we had some
stuffing yeah we did like the whole
chopsticks we did like a little bit of
the thanksgiving mashed potatoes which
is fine with me that's fine with me made
my own cranberry sauce
honestly today we had like for lunch i
had a turkey sandwich with like that
[ __ ] that cheese yeah and pickles and
mayonnaise that was delicious it was
good that was delicious
that's all i've had today i had a turkey
sandwich for lunch and then for dinner
and cheese on i had an egg salad
sandwich and i put that eatable
in there i put that eat them cheese on
it from it that was that was really good
yeah and uh the pickles really made it
yeah
um eat them cheese pickles and mayo on a
[ __ ] slabs of [ __ ] turkey breasts
yeah it was like big [ __ ] slabs yeah
like that big slabs of cheese too yeah
so yeah so
okay so everybody is
suspicious even when we first talked
about this case um everyone's suspicious
of her boyfriend because like i said
that's always like suspect number one in
these situations and especially
considering the fact that it's like hey
we were on this road trip and then he
comes back to florida
by himself
and it's just kind of like
i don't know what happened
um so the whole time they were gone like
while they were on their trip
they've been documenting documenting
their stuff on instagram
um
interestingly though and uh this is
pretty well documented august 12th
uh they were actually in 2021 they were
stopped by police near moab utah
uh because the two of them got into a
little bit of a domestic
dispute
now there is police video out there
which actually shows gabby petito
um talking about
a fight that she and her boyfriend
had had
and
the police at the time
concluded that gabby was actually the
aggressor
but they didn't agree they didn't like
arrest anybody at the time they just
said well we're just gonna like separate
you [ __ ] and like let's call it
into it
um
but in hindsight people were kind of
like upset about it they're like look uh
one you didn't uh
you know do a domestic violence thing on
her because she admitted that she had
started the fight
and also you didn't look into the
possibility
that maybe uh he had instigated the [ __ ]
like before you got there because there
had been some witness accounts that he
had actually like hit her
first before the cops got there and that
she was like covering up for him so
there was kind of like a whole thing
because they'd been together for a while
so they didn't know if there was like
some kind of
weird
thing going on where she was just like
saying yeah yeah it was me
now uh so there was that now more than a
month after this
incident where the comps are called in
in moab utah
september 19 2021
gabby potito's body was found at a
campground near the grand teton national
park that's in wyoming if you don't know
now uh when they did an autopsy they
determined that she had died about three
weeks prior
so probably not too long after the cops
had stopped them
uh she had died of blunt force injuries
to the head and neck and manual
strangulation
now
again very fishy
brian laundry drives back to his house
in florida in early september
but weirdly
uh he comes back without his girlfriend
which everybody thinks is weird
and then he also went missing not too
long after that
uh so yeah people thought that was very
strange
however
uh recently
they found what ended up happening was
that
uh brian laundry's parents
found something that belonged to him
like in this park like near their house
and when they searched
they actually found brian laundry's
remains
in this park in florida
and they also found a bunch of his stuff
they found uh his
revolver they found a backpack and they
found a notebook
they found that he had died from a
self-inflicted gunshot wound
uh the fbi didn't tell anybody what was
in the notebook but they did release to
the public
that when they searched the cell phone
records it appeared that what brian had
been trying to do
was that he had been sending texts
from his phone
to his girlfriend's phone
in an attempt to make it seem as though
his girlfriend was still alive even
though she was obviously dead because
they had already found her body
so that seemed very very suspicious
obviously because
he was trying to cover up her death he
knew she was dead and was like trying to
like make it look like she was still
alive
so uh yeah so at that point they found
his body he had killed himself
and
because they found this notebook which
they are not disclosing the contents of
but because they found these texts where
it very clearly appeared as though he
was trying to make his girlfriend seem
like she was still alive they concluded
that this [ __ ] as everyone
suspected
had killed his girlfriend and tried to
cover up that fact
and then come back to florida and killed
himself in an area where his body would
not be found until
uh quite a while later so this was
actually the first time that the
authorities had
actually blamed him
for killing gabby petito on you know
blamed him for that
um even though he'd been the prime
suspect all along obviously but like i
said
it it's one of those things where just
because you think somebody did it that
doesn't necessarily mean that you can
arrest them for it or you can like uh
conclusively you know think that they
did it you need like evidence
so the fact that they found
evidence in the fact that he tried to
cover up the fact of the death because
of the text messages they are now pretty
much convinced
that brian laundry
killed his girlfriend while they were on
the trip
probably when they had a fight
tried to cover up the fact came back to
florida and then tried to make it look
like she was still alive by like looking
like it text like he texted her but then
he couldn't take it and then he killed
himself
in a place that
you know they wouldn't find him for a
little while but they did find his body
they determined that he killed himself
and they found all the text messages so
that case is pretty much closed they
know that he [ __ ] did that [ __ ]
so now let's talk about a couple of
murder cases
now
let me see
let me have a drink first
you doing all right tom
yeah i haven't wanted a new one but i
just feel you have anything to say or no
i got nothing to say okay
just checking yeah good
strawduck78 says i would pay for a
richard bachman long walk or rage themed
shirt i don't know who that is huh no
it's uh it's stephen king
stephen king's uh yeah yeah those are
the um two of the stories that he wrote
the novellas that he were in uh the
bachmann books
i'm gonna write that down um i'll think
of something
or rage
i kind of feel like a lot of people
don't um
the thing about rage is that
that's kind of like about a school
shooter yeah
so
it's a little bit kind of like
controversial i guess i saw this video
that came up my suggestions earlier
today
that was called the stephen king story
nobody wants you to read yeah that was
just kind of like well you can still
read it though like let's not get
excited
i mean i have a book that still has it
in it and you can find it all over
youtube and
it's not like nobody wants to read you
can you can read it it's fine
but uh yeah
i get why because like i said it's about
school shooter but
nobody's stopping you from reading it
it's it's cool
all right so let's talk about this case
now this was a
i know that we talked about this case in
some context i did a search on our
channel
and i couldn't find the names and i
couldn't find the names in my faceless
villain book either
but i feel like we talked about this
okay so i feel like what happened with
this we probably talked about this
in
because you know how
when we did the show about the zodiac
and when they were looking into possible
suspects for the zodiac case they were
looking into other people
that did
lovers lane style murders because it was
a surprisingly not common but
not uncommon
um kind of mo like where you just go up
and like kill people in like [ __ ]
lovers lanes and cars and [ __ ]
so they were looking into this dude
named edward w edwards who
many people think is a serial killer
like look him up i think we talked about
him a few times and i think that maybe
we were talking about him
and in the context of his
possible crimes because he did do some
lovers
lovers lane type
crimes
they were talking about him as a suspect
for this crime so i because i recognize
these names so i think we probably
talked about this before but
this murder double murder
has been solved and it was solved very
very recently with uh dna
so this is the murder of lloyd bogle and
patricia
kolitsky
this might be
uh because it's more than 65 years old
so this might be
uh the oldest cold case that has been
solved so far not really sure about that
but it could be it's very old
so
what ended up happening this happened
back like i said in uh [ __ ] 19 what
was it 1956 1956
this happened
the evening of january 2nd 1956 uh you
know there was patty kolitsky
who was a junior at great falls high
school in montana
and lloyd bogle her boyfriend who was uh
an airman
and they went to a place uh near great
falls
along the sun
river the next day i guess they went
there like you know lay on the riverbank
make out whatever it was 1956.
the next day
they found three kids that were walking
to the beach
found lloyd bogle's dead body gunshot
wound to the head face down next to his
car
the day after that
a road worker
uh found a body and that turned out to
be patty kalitzki
five miles away uh from where the car
was
she had been shot in the head also
but had been raped
so starting in 2012 like i said this was
a very very old cold case and
uh i think that it was maybe when we
talked about edward w edwards
uh one of the proposed serial killers
that may have been the zodiac because he
did some lovers lane style murders
um so i kind of feel like this is how
that that was the context that we
brought this up in
um
so
starting in 2012
uh they were doing like a cold case
investigation of this
so they started doing dna testing
because they did find semen
inside
patty kolitsky's body
look at pookie pookie's on the show is
that great great why are you ready what
are you being crazy she's like what i'm
not i'm not kidding
you caught me fat earlier i'm out yeah
she's mad
man because it calls you fat she's
getting fat you got to put your ass on a
diet
she's like she doesn't care she's
rolling around i got a bad bad fat belly
she's not that fat you're just kidding
she's not fat she's not there she's
fluffy
she eats whenever she wants to i'm
feeding you too much
she's fluffy she begs and i'm like okay
all right i'll give you something well i
mean she's so cute yeah
it's not just food it's like whenever
like she wants to be
b-r-u-s-h-e-d yeah she wants you brushed
i can't say that word out loud because
like she knows what that word means and
she'll jump over there and be like
yeah she wants you to hit her with her
brush
she's funny yeah
and it's like she's a human child she
really does it's [ __ ] hilarious well
we kind of treat her like a human child
so we can't we
have only ourselves but she forced us to
do that we have only ourselves to blame
she forced us she is spoiled rotten yeah
she's spoiled brad she's and and she
will not take no for an answer oh she
absolutely she'll start smacking on the
[ __ ] she'll start smacking on them
she's like you know do it
and you're like no i'll tell her no
about ten times
and she'll like no let me in
i'm like
okay so she does get her way yeah and i
let her into the closet and she goes oh
there's nothing in here i'm like yeah
there's nothing in there then she'll run
out of blog well what she does with the
br br ush is that she'll jump up on the
sink yeah and then she'll start yelling
and then i'm like man i don't have time
for this right now and i'll kind of look
at her like i don't have time for this
and then she starts like deliberately
pushing [ __ ] like off the [ __ ] yeah
she's like i'm gonna break all your
stuff and tear it all up if you don't do
what i want like right now yeah but you
guys said she's big boned yeah that's
what it is
she's just big bump oh yeah
yeah some some females can carry weight
don't pick on pools other females can't
carry weight it all depends on how it's
a banks
okay and they're all like that minx
kitties are your build is short and
stubby and round round yeah um she's the
same cat
that that gorilla called all ball
yeah what was that gorilla's name coco
coca
she called she called it all ball
and if you look at her you go yeah it is
all round yeah the body's round the
head's around yeah because if you know
you guys know the famous gorilla that
could
did sign language yeah coco and she had
a pet kitten it was one of those sadly
the kitten got run over by car let's not
talk about that but um the kitten the
gorilla named it all ball because it was
a banks
and manx cats
like pookie
uh are very round round they have little
round heads round heads roundabouts
round bodies and they have very very
short legs in relation to their bodies
and their front legs are shorter than
their back legs yeah so a lot of people
uh have called like they the way they
move is like a bunny hop yeah because
they have longer back legs and short
legs and she does have very short legs
in relation to you yeah so the gorilla
called it yeah everything's round
oh wow it's all a round ball that's
right i call her that sometimes but then
i feel bad because the original oddball
got right over it
so i was like i don't i don't want to
like i don't want to jinx it you know
what i mean so there's that but
that's really weird how perceptive that
gorilla was yeah
she was just calling it the way it
looked yeah it's superficial just like
it's all
yeah yeah i mean she's not round round
but now i see it yeah you can see you
can see
an artist it's round yeah everything's
around
and like i would start off by [ __ ]
drawing a series of [ __ ] round
spheres and her little legs are like
really short and if you see her like
running yeah
like i don't is she listening she's not
listening
if you watch her run it's like kind of
hilarious because it's like she has this
little run like
and like her little belly like swings
back and forth and like she has i call
her like the gunslinger yeah because she
has like her little short legs are like
like that yeah
she's like it's so funny no need for me
is saying it's on me i need to ease up
because i'm the one that's feeding her
too much yeah i know
she begs
and you can't resist her because she's
too cute you gotta see it the bagging
routine she comes in the bedroom she
knows how to do it like because i'm very
manipulative i'm in the office until
like
seven eight o'clock at night yeah
and then like i take a shower i go in
the room and then we go in the room and
like watch a movie and as soon as we're
both in the bedroom
pookie knows that that's meat stick time
yeah so she comes
doing her little
run that she does
into the bedroom and she runs over to
the uh nightstand because she knows
that's where the meat sticks are in the
drawer and then she goes there and she
sits
and stares
with her big eyes
she stares at daddy
stairs and stairs if you don't pay
attention she jumps up on the nightstand
and starts pushing [ __ ] off yeah she'll
pull up and not stand shut
down on the ground she's [ __ ]
she's like if you have a drink up there
she'll push it it's like if you have his
uh you know earbuds she'll push that off
she'll stand up she'll stand up on her
back legs and grab the bottom of a
coffee cup and start backing up and
pulling
it's [ __ ] funny she's like pay
attention yeah look we can't talk about
this we got to finish the show i'm just
saying good i just have two more
shortcuts
so
yeah and then we could talk about cats
if you want to
yeah and somebody has something to eat
when the show's up okay
so yeah so i was talking about like
yeah lover's lane murders
so this is a case that i feel like we've
brought up before because these names
are very familiar
so yeah so like i said they found uh the
kid 1956
shot in the head next to his car they
found his girlfriend the next day also
shot in the head but had been raped
2012 they have the cold case
people
looking into the [ __ ]
uh so they went to do dna because like i
said they found a whole dna profile
because
patricia kolinsky had been raped
so they had semen so they could do a
whole
dna workup now for a long time they
thought maybe one of the suspects was a
whitey bulger the famous gangster
i ran into him
did you yes i did when i was living in
boston when was that i told the story
already
i don't remember that though i lived it
[ __ ] um in somerville
there's an apartment up there in winter
hill
and right across the street from [ __ ]
the apartment was a little candy shop
that was never open
and one day i was coming back from the
goth club and saw a [ __ ] five or six
guys [ __ ] spread out [ __ ] guarding
all the [ __ ] streets to come in and
going to this damn candy shop and they
were hauling all these filing cabinets
out of that [ __ ] candy shop in the
middle of the night like three o'clock
in the morning and putting it in a damn
van
and that was whitey bulger and his
[ __ ] dudes it was the summerville
summer
what was it winter hill gang
well they thought that he was like when
i saw that dude and his [ __ ] friends
and they were [ __ ] looking at me
[ __ ] grin and i was like i was out of
the army by then i said man this is a
security job here who the [ __ ] are these
dudes and [ __ ] walked up on the
[ __ ] with the outer century and he's
sitting there [ __ ] grinning at me
like
how you doing man you better [ __ ]
watch your p's and q's i was just going
i was just going to my apartment that
was him though
that was him i don't think i saw whitey
but it was his dudes
he died recently did he not yeah he's
also a suspect and i don't know if this
is he's also a suspect in the very
famous lady of the dunes case they said
he might have been involved in [ __ ]
white slavery
well he um had been arrested for rape
in this time period in 1951
so that's why they thought that he was
the suspect in this particular case
because he was like
thought to have raped a girl in this
area
like in this uh time period they thought
that he was in this area at this uh
period and like i mentioned earlier
uh one of the people that was brought up
a lot of times as a suspect for this
which i think we also did as well was
edward w edwards because he was kind of
a guy like i said he's a dude that's
brought up a lot in conversations about
the zodiac because he was a guy that
is
thought to be involved with a lot of
lovers lane style murders
so he was a suspect as well
but
i have to say they did some dna [ __ ] for
this case
and they determined that the people that
the person that was responsible for this
was a dude that was named hold on i had
it just now
was a dude named
where is it
something gould
mr gold
i can't find it now
i lost my place in the [ __ ] notes
great
yeah it was a guy named gould that was
his last name
so it wasn't edward edwards it wasn't
whitey bulger it wasn't anybody like
that
2019
they actually linked
uh the dna to this dude named gold and
they find they found out
that what happened
uh
this dude had actually died in 2007
and they had cremated his body
but they actually got dna from his kids
uh and that was what caused the match
now what they found out
this wasn't a serial killer it wasn't
anything like that which like i said
just goes show you can't trust anybody
this dude
that they found
the dna inside of the murder victim
he lived about a mile away from patty
the female victim
um
and he
work he lived and worked like just a
couple blocks away from her
um the weird thing about it though was
that he didn't have any criminal history
prior to that
and he didn't have any criminal history
after that that doesn't mean he didn't
do anything that just means he didn't
get caught
so
weird thing about it though was that
about a month after
this was in 1956 month after he after
that crime happened
he suddenly like moved
and then he like moved his family
somewhere else he had a family and kids
and everything
and as far as i know like i don't know
if he didn't do it again or if he just
didn't get caught again
but
his dna
was
found
on the murder victim
so
he did that [ __ ]
and apparently he got away with it
because he's dead he died
before they figured out who the [ __ ]
that was but they found out who it was
and it wasn't a serial killer it wasn't
anything or it wasn't a serial killer
would know about maybe he was a serial
killer and we just don't know about it
but they found out who did it
and
that's i i wish i could remember where
we talked about that case i kind of feel
like we talked about that
i feel like we talked about that on the
zodiac show because we were talking
about edward edwards
yeah
and
he had done a lot of he was a suspect in
a lot of other lovers lane style murders
which is what this was and i think i
brought it up on this one because i knew
the names like when i saw it
now let me talk about this last case
this is an unsolved murder and i talked
about this case
i wrote about this case in my faceless
villain volume 2.
so this is actually one case that i
wrote about
in that book
that has been solved
they found the person that did it
like after i wrote the book okay look i
found the [ __ ] photo of where i was
talking about
all right
see that apartment right there that's
where i used to live i used to live in
that third floor right there
where i was talking about where i saw
why the bulger was right here i'm gonna
try to there was a candy store right
here i'm gonna show it to you
i found it
that's at broadway
broadway and [ __ ] masseter i forgot
what it was i'm gonna try to go over
there i'm laughing at like nerdy for me
too says no you didn't just check to see
if she was listening who pookie oh yeah
that was a long time ago
but i do though because
yeah
um she understands words yeah i have to
spell them
i have to spell them because if i say a
word she's like
it's called broadway in maine she's
being cool though broadway in main
street in medford
okay
i'm going to show you guys
let me show you guys where that was let
me show you where whitey bulger's
[ __ ]
building was
okay
that's the that's the apartment building
i used to live in across the street from
this
is where they were under unloading those
see if i can try to find hole i gotta
look at it
where is that [ __ ]
yeah i mean oh it's torn down it's torn
down i mean it's torn down
okay it's not there anymore what's there
now is just
more apartment buildings
that didn't used to be there there used
to be a shop there
okay i mean whitey bulger just died like
fairly recently yeah and i feel like he
was i don't you know i don't know if he
killed all these people but because he
was in an area at the time and he was
known to be like kind of like a rapist
and probably a murderer
so if he was in an area when like some
unsolved murders happened then obviously
he was going to be assassinated they
tore down his little [ __ ] um can't
fake candy and she [ __ ] up my
the short they tore down his little fake
candy shop
now they got a liquor store there that
used to be a police supply place and
then next to it used to be a brazilian
restaurant it was [ __ ] great but
looking at this place kind of [ __ ]
brings me back i lived in there for uh
three years
in that apartment
back in the 90s
man [ __ ] they changed it a bit
it takes you back well it's been a long
time yeah it's been a long time
i'm just saying well look into the
391 broadway that was the name of that
building
that was my old apartment right there
[ __ ]
listen right there third floor
that third floor right there on that's
where my finger is that's where i used
to live there
that was my [ __ ] little gothic
[ __ ] pad man
yeah
and that's where the you [ __ ] up my
lighting again yeah damon
yeah amazed me
still [ __ ] up yeah
so they tore whitey bulger's place down
it was across the street from that
winter hill
well like i said i feel like he's uh you
know he was one of the ones that's
brought up a lot like i said lady the
dunes case
uh if you know anything about that
unidentified it's gentrified now i'm
looking at it man but it was kind of it
was a little bit of the ghetto back in
the time when i was there
yeah yeah but this particular case that
whitey bulger was a suspect in not him
they found some dna and it was just like
a dude
that knew the girl so seems like a
stalker type of situation
so let's talk about
uh for the last case this is a case that
i uh talked about because i knew this
name when i was like
i did like a google search of
cold cases that were solved in 2020 or
2021
and then i was looking for names that
looked familiar that i'd written about
in my book or like that we've done on
the show and this name came up because
i've written about it in faceless
villain volume two
and this is the case of morin maureen
brubacher farley and this was solved
uh very recently
unsolved murder case
so let's uh go back this happened in
cedar rapids iowa what have i said about
iowa
so many like unsolved murders in iowa
i don't know if it's because they have
more unsolved murders than normal
or
just because they have better record
keeping than normal it might be the
second thing
but i did find a lot of unsolved murders
and there are a lot of like good online
resources of unsolved murders in iowa so
maybe um all states don't have that
so uh october of 2021 this is fairly
recent
police in cedar rapids iowa
announced that they had closed
this unsolved murder case which like i
said i learned about
uh in my faceless building villain
volume two
this case is 50 years old that happened
in 1971
before i was even born
now
what happened
maureen brubacher farley was 17 years
old
they found her body
uh september 24th 1971
in the ravine
uh in cedar rapids iowa
uh she had last been seen alive on the
morning of september 17th
now what ended up happening okay so she
didn't show up for work she worked at a
diner
and she didn't show up and her boss
reported her missing
a week later
two
little boys
found her body laying on the trunk
of an abandoned car
like in a
uh like kind of ravine like at the edge
of a bridge like almost like somebody
had
tossed her off the bridge but not really
because her body wasn't [ __ ] up it
looked like somebody like just laid it
there
on the trunk of a of a car
so
yeah she had uh she was partially
clothed
she didn't have any shoes on
but her feet were clean
so they were like well obviously she was
left here like she was carried here she
didn't walk here because her feet would
be dirty otherwise
uh they determined that her cause of
death was a skull fracture somebody had
like beaten her in the head with a blunt
object
uh also she had been raped so there was
that
uh and police at the time even in 1971
figured out that she had been carried
there and left on the trunk of this
particular car
now even at the time back in the 70s
one of the suspects was a dude named
george smith
he wasn't
a friend of hers but he was an
acquaintance he was a dude that like
hung out at the diner that she worked at
and some people said that he was kind of
a weirdo so that like everybody had to
like look into that
uh he also
supposedly
um
he worked at a hauling service
and
so he drove a truck he also kind of like
worked part-time at a liquor store which
was near where she lived
so it could have been a stalking
situation where he was like watching her
all the time
he had been interviewed back in 1971
but they couldn't find enough evidence
to charge him with anything
um
so they kind of had to let him go they
asked him to do a polygraph he would not
um but that's not illegal
so
there you go
now during the autopsy
uh they did actually do like a swab of
her body and like i said this is 1971 so
they couldn't really do anything much at
the time but they did save the evidence
uh from her
you know uh they did like a semen
thing and
they did a whole dna
breakdown of that later
like the cold case people did
and they determined that this person
george smith
who is a person that
worked in this liquor store
lived right around her
he was the one
that had raped her
and probably killed her
uh because his dna was a complete match
unfortunately by the time they figured
that out
he was already dead
so
they couldn't really do much about it
honestly they um the only thing that's
good
is that they did the dna and they said
okay well that's the guy that did it
he's dead now
what are you gonna do
her mom
uh was still alive she was 86
so they were able to go to her mom and
say hey we found the person that raped
and murdered your daughter
this is him he's already dead we can't
do anything about it
her dad
had died in 2002
so
sadly
but at least her mom got some closure on
it
i don't know
it seems like
very very like cold comfort but at least
that
2019 interestingly they had also uh they
did a they solved another cold case
uh through dna
there was another i don't think i read
about this one but there was another
woman called uh michelle martinko
and she was actually in 1979 she was
found dead like stabbed to death
and they actually used dna to like uh
solve her case too
and they found the guy that did it who
was named jerry burns
but
so
dna now they're solving like a lot of
stuff from back in the old days and like
i'm kind of i'm here for it
i don't know though it's kind of
as i said it's kind of cold comfort
because after all this time
i don't know i kind of i don't know i i
don't have a family member that was
murdered or is missing or anything like
that like maybe that would be some
comfort to you it's like at least we
found the person that did it even if
they're dead now
even if we can't punish them it's just
kind of like at least you know
yeah i don't know i don't know how i
would feel about it
i'm sitting there looking at pookie look
at pookie she's in a pile of toys
looking happy as [ __ ] she's just sitting
it's [ __ ] ridiculous no need for me
too is like laughing at me like checking
with her about yeah yeah
yeah look at her it's [ __ ] funny
so
is that it
yeah all right i mean
but like i said she's not dumb
and she knows certain words yeah she
doesn't we're talking so we have to
spell them you're right
because if you say them out loud she's
like what
and then she's like she wants to get
yeah she's getting ready to fall asleep
all right so uh why don't we go ahead
and check out now and i'll uh go get us
something to eat
okay sound good we've been how long has
the show been going uh three hours and
53 yeah that's about right okay yeah
i mean hopefully you guys enjoyed the
show i thought i had a good job on the
show we got a good time
i got through all the stuff
hopefully it wasn't too incoherent we'll
see you guys tomorrow
no not tomorrow friday after friday yeah
friday we're gonna do the side track
show yeah are we gonna move that to six
as well yeah yeah probably okay okay
so all right so come back friday evening
at 6 p.m eastern standard time
for a sidetrack show
and that'll be fun
um but thank everybody for coming by
this evening thank you for super chats
if you gave some what are you laughing
at
are you laughing at me that's all right
shut it down jenny go ahead and shut it
down why don't you shut it down
laughing at me yeah thank you thank you
guys for showing up and we'll see you
guys uh friday friday evening friday
night bye-bye all right bye